Fly.
We're ready.
Damn.
That was quick.
Jesus little wheezes.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you.
I said my name,
fuck.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by ting.
Ting is a mobile cell phone company.
I shouldn't say mobile shouldn't say carphone either.
Don't say that.
People know you're over.
40 thing is a cell phone company,
I guess you'd call it a cell phone comedy that does things differently.
And what they do is they,
they,
they use the sprint backbone and they do everything their way.
No contracts,
no early termination fees.
They sell you the phone instead of this bullshit when you,
if you buy a phone from a regular provider,
not a regular provider,
but one of the big ones,
what you're doing is you're not really buying the phone for the most part.
What you're doing is you're paying for some of the phone upfront.
Like the phone only costs 200 bucks with,
uh,
you know,
with a contract,
the phone is really like 600 bucks.
But they trick you into getting in debt with them and then when you want to
leave they go,
oh well you can't leave unless you give us this early termination fee.
You,
they fuck you.
They,
they make you pay.
Got Down at,
they take your money.
Bert Kreischer
is that what they're doing with the cell phones?
Yes.
Do you not understand this?
I fuck.
I've been so out of the cell phone game for so long.
How do you get out of cell phone?
My wife does it all.
That's nice.
But she'll be like,
yeah,
you're available for an upgrade.
You can get a new phone.
You just pass it off to her.
Oh Dude.
She's like a great lab partner.
That's great.
Cheat off her homework to help.
She helps me on the tests but I,
but I'm the cool guy on the table.
So all the other lab partners like think art table must be fun.
Don't you earn the money though?
That's what I,
that's the part I do and I make us friends with people.
Like my wife will meet the people,
but I'm the closer on the franchise player.
There you go.
Um,
98% of people would save money with tank.
The way Tim handles it,
you don't pay like a certain set amount per month either.
And I think in the future is good to be with all cell phone companies are going
to be forced to do.
I remember back in the day
when cell phone companies,
they used to uh,
they used to charge,
you have your roaming and you could roam by just driving your fucking friends
house by the lutes in Tampa.
If you went to my house,
you were fucking roaming.
Isn't that crazy?
And you'd see the thing on the top of your phone.
Ah Shit,
I'm roaming
and it wasn't far.
And you know,
it also used to be that long distance would cost you a fuck load of money.
If you would call someone in New York,
it would cost you a fuck load of money.
All that stuff is gone now it's gone.
Long distance on your phone is gone and your cell phone's gone.
It's all gone.
And the reason why it's gone is because it's a good reason.
It's because of competition and competition is also causing a
company like tink to show up and when Tim does is they sell you the very best
android phones available.
They have the Samsung Galaxy note three they have the HTC one m eight which is
the newest HTC one that they just got.
They got Samsung Galaxy s five the LG flex,
all the cool dope ass android phones they sell them to at a very reasonable
rate.
You own it and you can cancel at any moment.
98% of people would save money with Ting and if you go to rogan.ting.com you
will save 25 bucks off of any of your first delicious android phones.
That's rogan.ting.com we're also brought to you by on it.
That's O.
N.
I.
T.
I haven't taken my aunt today.
I'm like sound stupider than normal alpha branch.
Let's look.
I'll bring this morning
sweet pitches would onit is,
is a human optimization website.
What we do is we sell you everything that we have found to be beneficial.
Whether it's for strength and conditioning,
whether it's for cognitive enhancing performance,
whether it's for athletic performance,
like shroom tech,
sport.
If you're a person that works out,
I will guarantee you this.
Try shroom tech sport.
You will have more energy when you exercise and it won't be some bullshit
caffeine,
any like speedy type feeling.
It's all based on the court accepts mushrooms.
It's really fascinating stuff.
Quarter sips sinensis thousands of years of use by people.
Not really smarter than you,
but they knew more shit about mushrooms,
the five HTP and the new mood actually.
Like if you get obsessive compulsive about stuff,
it will dial that shit back 100% really?
Oh yes.
Well I'll get into like little spirals sometimes.
So for you it does that for me.
100% if you take new mood and I'm not even fucking around,
I think it,
I,
I can a market difference when you get obsessive about something and you can't
let it go,
that's weird.
So don't think that you're obsessive.
Thing is like a mental,
like a chemical thing,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh completely.
I think,
I think what I do is I steal all my dopamine at night for my body and then
during the day my body's going like Jones and for it like,
and then so what it does to get rid of it is just makes me think about one
thought over and over and over again.
Like we're like a bad thought.
Do you ever try to do something about that other than take new mood?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard to get out of men.
I'll tell you a story when we get done this had about when I thought I had
genital warts.
Oh Jesus.
Let's get it.
That was the first time I dealt with this.
Get done right now so we can get into that.
Go to Rogan
on@dotcomonnit.com.
Use the code word rogue and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All of the supplements have a 100% money back guarantee.
The first 30 pills you have 90 days.
Try it.
You don't like it?
You don't even have to return the product.
You don't have to return the bottle.
You know,
just say this stuff sucks.
You get your money back.
It's because we're trying to sell you the best shit that we possibly can find
where no one's trying to rip you off and if you don't like it,
you're some kind of fucking Weirdo and we don't want to do business with you
anyway,
son.
Alright,
to the music bird crashes here.
Let's make shit happen.
Let's get real.
Let's get freaky with it.
The first beer has been crying.
Logan Powerful.
Bert Kreischer.
It's just me and Bert and Jamie.
Even though I told motherfucking Brian to be here on time,
I call him at 11 o'clock waking him up
and go off fucking be there on time.
You got to be up early tomorrow.
No problem.
That fuck no.
It's like how an employee like that.
I only know what it's like to have him as a friend and that's fucking
fascinating.
It's fascinating.
Yeah.
Imagine relying on him.
Anyway,
we're here.
We're queer.
Get used to it.
It's so funny that you guys like are still as close as you arch and considering
that you guys met via the online and like him doing videos because everyone's
like,
if you have a podcast,
everyone,
everyone's like,
I want to be red band,
I want to be a red band,
I'll come to your house,
man,
we'll hang out.
I can't imagine how like,
it's like you guys are that,
that that worked.
You know,
that you and Brian worked that,
that he wasn't a lunatic and he just,
and you guys just,
well he's definitely a lunatic,
but he's,
he's talented and he's funny.
He's,
he's in his own weird ways.
You know,
he's a quirky little guy.
Yeah.
He's a an odd fellow.
It's an interesting mix.
Thanks dude.
Being in,
uh,
like getting the trickle down effect of your friends into my life has been
fascinating.
Like Amber Lyon,
I had her on my podcast.
I only had her on my podcast cause like,
I know you guys had a fascinating conversation than Dunkin talk to her.
Someone was like,
you guys should podcast.
She comes over my house.
She's fucking amazing.
She's cool.
Really insanely smart.
It's like,
and like Stan hope I was telling you was Stan hope,
standard hope.
And I just met the other night and like hung out.
We had known each other through stand up,
he calls,
he calls me,
he's like,
I'm coming in hot and I'm not a pro burst house.
And you know Stan hope when he's like that shaky morning,
I am going to,
I'm going to be there early.
All right.
Okay.
So I told my wife,
I go,
I'm gonna go run and get beer for Stan hope and you can hang out with him.
She's like,
I'm not going.
That was Doug Stanhope like no fucking way.
So I go,
you go get beer,
I'll wait for Stan hope.
And they just happened to meet on the front porch.
And here's the thing that no one gets about.
Stan hope.
He is a very real person.
Like he's not like,
they think he's this guy on stage.
It's like,
ah,
abortion and AIDS and rape and,
but he's like a genuinely a real person.
So we go back,
we drink,
we do a podcast for like fucking four hours.
What time was this weird?
Three in the afternoon.
It was the morning,
three in the afternoon.
We Start and then my wife,
and this is what blew me away,
is my wife goes,
you know,
just,
hey,
we're serving the girl's dinner.
Doug,
would you like to stay for dinner?
Now we all are.
Everyone knows the answer.
You're expecting to hear us.
No,
I'm not going to hang out with your family,
but Doug is such a real fucking person.
He's like,
I'd like that.
So we sat down with my daughters.
Fuck.
Why do you find that so odd?
Because,
so maybe it's me because I,
but so many people would be like,
no,
no.
Like that intimacy,
like to share a meal with a family.
That intimacy is not,
everyone has a de,
I dunno,
maybe it's,
I've known Doug for so long.
You've known Doug for,
I think the,
what people know of dog is different than what you know of dog.
Well,
I think it's one of those things where whenever someone's a comedian,
it's like this rabble rousing drinking,
you know,
a abortion proponent.
Yeah.
Like Doug is,
you just assume that it's the act and then he's just like this like Kinison guy
like all day long.
But when Doug talks about something on stage it's because these are like actual
opinions at,
he's formulated this.
One of the things,
it's a real problem with that kind of edgy comedy.
One of the reasons why edgy comedy a lot of times sucks.
The DIS tastefulness a lot of it would,
it comes from is a lot of these fucking guys that are faking it.
That's what they're doing is they're trying to be edgy.
They're trying to find the edge point of view.
I mean how many times have you gone to like either an open Mike night or a
showcase night and as a comic that goes up it's seen a bunch of it like really
mean shit.
It's not funny,
but he thinks it's going to be funny if he just edgy,
you know,
if he just says something inflammatory or rude or mean or you know.
Yeah,
I was,
I was that comic I think to an extent,
like I didn't know what my voice was.
Yeah.
I think a lot of us were.
I definitely wasn't the beginning.
You,
you become that because you're just trying to,
I always described it to stages.
The comedy,
the first stage is just trying to figure out what works.
Like you're terrified.
You don't want to bomb you just trying to just,
it's almost like you have tools like,
well,
how do I cut this wood?
Does it,
can I use a saw?
Yes,
the saw works.
Uh,
can I use a hammer?
No,
he can't cut with a hammer.
Okay.
Don't try to hammer again.
And then there's a while.
We were like,
stay the fuck away from hammering
shit and then people will give you advice.
Dude.
I brought up a hammer and Fort Lauderdale and the audience killed me.
Okay,
no more hammered.
Otello go,
dude.
I like the way you use that hammer and you're like,
even though it bombed,
I'm sticking with the fucking hammer.
Hammer back with the hammer.
When a rework the hammer,
I tell likes the hammer.
It's so true.
If your friend got,
it becomes a real problem with comics,
by the way.
Shout out to the young comedians out there listening,
do not try to make the back of the room laugh.
Oh,
that becomes a real issue and it's ruined.
Guys' careers were comics
say obscure Shit just to make their comedian friends go,
ah,
you are only making someone laugh.
Who knows you're doing like anti comedy.
There's guys that have like that.
It worked.
Talented,
funny guys that thought that like telling an actual funny joke was beneath them
and what they wanted to do was only make the comics laugh because those are
their peers and they fucked themselves.
They,
there's a lot of guys that fuck themselves doing that.
The differences,
when you hear someone who does make the back of the room laugh with his obscure
joke,
he didn't write it like I'll use it tells an example.
I remember the line was,
I was sitting in the back with Patrice and I,
by the way,
I apologize if my memory of this,
of these events is an accurate,
but,
but I'm telling you what.
I remember I was with Patrice in the packet,
uh,
comedy cellar,
sitting next priest betrayals.
And I weren't like good friends at all,
but Lisa Lampanelli walked through and he made a joke about her.
This is before she was who she is today.
He made a joke about her and she laughed and then he didn't,
and then he said they had,
the joke was,
and I hate that I'm even saying this now,
but he's like,
oh,
look at her.
She's,
she's smiling like the special needs girl.
After she got raped by the softball team or the baseball team.
Oh,
fear.
God's tomorrow.
And I remember Patrice and our own fucking stitches and we were like,
but he wasn't,
he was really hoping everyone would get that,
but no one got it except for the two of us.
What do you mean by get it?
Like get the joke,
like the joke was,
it was very,
it's very obscure,
but there's a book written and I was,
I only know this because I was working at Barnes and noble at the time.
There was a book written about a baseball team that raped her mentally
challenged girl in Jersey and they all got away with it.
Yeah.
They all got away with it and,
but the joke was,
I'm,
I'm fucking butchering this and tells him he be like,
I never said that.
I don't cause now it's like out of context.
I'm making him sound bad,
but I don't mean to.
But I remember Patrice and I laughed fucking hysterically and she laughed.
She laughed.
She laughed at the joke was,
oh look at her.
She's laughing.
Like those special needs girls that just got raped by the baseball team and
said,
okay,
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Like the special needs girl didn't understand that.
What had just happened was horrible to her.
Dave was making that analogy that she didn't understand that he wasn't being
nice.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
People give a lot of shit to Lisa Lampanelli people give a lot of shit.
Lisa Lampanelli and I don't get along.
Really?
Yeah.
How come you guys don't get along?
I was doing radio one time in Tampa with my buddy cowhead and I was,
I lived in town.
I wasn't doing dates.
I was just hanging out and uh,
and uh,
my mom was visiting my family and I'd go in and do radio in the morning and she
came by and she was like,
he needs to leave.
And it's like,
oh,
he's not promoting anything.
He's just a here.
She's like,
yeah,
I don't do co radio with other comics.
And he's like,
yeah,
but he's a friend of the show.
He just,
he'll trust me.
Births good.
He'll just laugh,
he'll have a good time.
It'll set you up.
And she was like,
well then I don't do the show.
And he's like,
well,
he's my friend.
I'm not gonna ask him to fucking leave.
She was like,
you either leaves or I leave.
And I was like,
and I actually kind of newer and so I went,
I went to go say something to her and when,
I guess as soon as she saw me,
she fucking bolt it.
That's why I was like,
what the fuck was that?
Like I would never,
this was a long time to shoot.
Not so long ago.
She probably don't remember.
But like,
uh,
probably nine years ago,
it's seven years ago.
And I just was like,
I was like,
I was,
cause I wanted to pair like the biggest fucking compliment because I'd known her
when she would wear the gold chains on stage
and the gold chains and she used to go on stage with the,
with a huge Mercedes emblem around her neck.
Yeah.
And go rings all over her hands,
swear to God and,
and,
and be like a rapper.
Like,
oh no,
Yo,
I'm down with the black dude.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a fought out act like she has like her act now is a lot more clean.
She would wear like a costume on stage and I,
and I wanted to compliment her and maybe she,
maybe she was afraid I'd say that.
I don't know.
But I wanted to compliment her and say,
you're killing it.
Like how?
I was excited to see her,
but she didn't want me in the room.
That's wild.
Maybe she takes so much shit or took so much shit from comedic so that she just
didn't want have anything to do with the,
the possibility of being judged.
I could relate to that feeling totally.
Especially if she did a lot of,
you know,
she experimented with a lot of stuff and tried really hard and a lot of people
like gave her a hard time for her racial jokes.
Saying that she was trying too hard to be edgy and they would just be really
mean to her.
But
I never got into that man.
I might take on a comedy is if I don't like it,
why would I be mad at you?
Like I get it.
If it sucks,
I don't want to listen to it.
I don't want to be there,
but why would I be mad at you like for me to want to sabotage someone?
I would never do that.
So I could never do that.
And I was I a n n if you make me laugh,
I can't help it.
You make me laugh.
Lisa Lampanelli made me laugh.
Maybe it's just fucking too many dudes are fucking,
whether,
you know,
maybe,
maybe it was just too much.
So she just had this keep your eyes on the prize type thing in her head and,
and you know,
this guy's gonna fuck with my vibe.
Get 'em out.
Probably.
I mean I was a lot more,
I was really burned up about it when it happened and I was like,
I was like,
Fuck Lisa Lampanelli it,
but I don't care.
I don't think,
I don't feel that way at all now I'm,
I'm so,
it's neat to see her succeed and like the global kind of way that she is.
But yeah,
so this is like 2005 ish probably.
She was getting a lot of heat for being a hack back then by a lot of comics
because that was the one she was just starting to become successful.
And you know that thing when people just start to become successful,
the wave of resentment from all the fucking,
all the Comedians,
that just shit on you dude.
I think that,
I think that makes people not want to succeed.
Oh that's crazy.
I think there are shops,
office sabotaging people where you just,
Oh I don't think maybe it's third fucking,
they were never going to,
they're just looking for a reason to not succeed.
If that's the case,
if it's because somebody calls you a hack.
I'm obsessed right now with the,
with the type of comic that um,
the,
maybe the art form of standup isn't as important as fame and like getting to
like the fame of it.
Why don't you be obsessed,
not obsessed about honestly because uh,
not obsessed about it but it's definitely where my head's at right now cause I
think in promoting the book that I'm promoting non fucking stop.
You like this disconnect
from,
from reality and you've,
and you then I look at like guys that are not really comics per se,
but then go out and,
and it's just more about being famous as opposed to being,
you know what I mean?
Is that making any sense?
Totally.
Do you ever take an acting class?
No.
Have you ever took an acting class?
You'd be around those fucking people.
24 seven the fucking empty.
That's all they do.
Yeah.
They're just looking to get it.
Or you know what they really should have.
They should have reality TV classes.
If you really wanted to get sick people just,
this is how you get a it.
That's what we should do.
We should start a fucking seminar on how to become a reality TV star reality TV
stars.
Exactly what I'm talking about.
They're like the guys who just,
it's,
it's not about anything other than just being famous and,
and,
and you and I could probably qualify to teach that.
I mean,
you're on trip flip.
Yeah.
You were on your other shows before that.
Those are all sort of reality shows,
you know?
And me fear factor.
That's once a minute.
That's sort of a reality show too.
I mean it's all reality,
you know.
But if we wanted to do that,
we've wanted to do a quote unquote reality show,
we easily could get that done.
You know,
we could,
we could start coaching people on that would be hilarious.
Coaching people on how to be like the most vapid reality star.
This is what you have to do.
It teach them about conflict.
You got to get involved with co in conflict with people online.
It's many famous people as possible.
Twitter wars are good for business.
Like teach them about Twitter wars,
teach them how to make youtube videos,
calling people out and you know,
this is the way to get it is the most amount of hits.
Photoshop your head on porn stars,
bodies release it all over the Internet.
People think it's real.
You gotta have a porn tape if you can have a porn tape get appointed.
But if you have a little Dick,
stay away from the porn tape.
God,
can you imagine if you,
if you have a porn tape and it backfires.
Like if you do a porn tape,
but you got a little tiny deck,
like you have no reference for what it,
how big a dick is and you're like,
don't watch porn.
Yeah.
Maybe it's like a comic who's never really watched comedy.
They go on stage.
I don't know what you're doing.
You never really watched porn.
Didn't that guy who was the fucking shooter in Santa Barbara say that he didn't
watch porn because he would get jealous of the men in the porn videos?
I'm pretty sure that that that was something that,
that crazy fucking said.
Tech Kid.
I read the,
I read his manifesto.
I think he,
if he had had sex once,
he'd be like,
oh,
there's none of this is fucking worth it.
I watched the video.
I did,
I wasn't going to,
but yesterday I found myself watching it.
I just clicking through and looking at other stuff online and this w one of the
reasons why I watched it is because it's now become this really odd thing where
it's these,
uh,
feminists and men's rights groups or like using it as a platform to do battle.
It's become like this battlefield,
is that the yes,
yes.
Women can or no?
Yes.
All women and I think what their campaign is,
what they're trying to do with this Hashtag is they're saying
[inaudible] guys are saying not every guy is like him and what they're saying
is,
yeah,
but yes,
all women are subject to those assholes and that yes,
all women get fucked with.
Yes.
All women experience misogyny.
All women experience sexism.
My problem with all this from both sides is that it's not going to fix mentally
deranged people and we're also not being completely objective with why he is the
way he is.
There's obviously something really fucking wrong with your brain if you can go
out and shoot a bunch of people and then shoot yourself.
Okay.
Yeah,
we,
I think we could all agree on that.
All agree on that and obviously he had some extreme issues with his personality.
If you watch the video and you don't have to,
I mean I just did yesterday,
but if you watch that video you can see like he's a psychopath.
There's something really wrong with this guy or something so wrong burgers.
Who knows?
I don't know what that means.
You know I don't like all these wacky labels when it comes to mental illnesses
cause I'm not sure I trust them all.
You know,
like he's on the spectrum.
Oh,
is he really?
What are you,
is this,
can you weigh that?
Can you put that spectrum on a scale?
Can you make that guy uh,
jumping a tank of water and it reads how autistic he is?
Like I don't,
I'm not sure.
I believe you.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like Adhd.
The kid's got ADHD does he did it.
It didn't.
Someone just say that they invented that and that it's not real.
I mean,
what does it mean he doesn't like school?
Who the fuck does,
it's boring as shit.
You put me in school right now.
You would think I need drugs.
If they made me go back to high school right now,
they would put me on fucking Ritalin.
Like,
this kid's got problems.
He's got the Adhd.
He's never going to succeed in this life.
He's never going to be a functional part of society unless he takes medication.
It becomes a fucking square peg.
You can't be living your life as a round hole.
You fuckhead.
Yeah.
What do you think you're going to do is just go sit on the stage to make people
laugh.
There's no fucking,
I love it.
I love that analogy of a,
if you put them in a tank of water,
that's what they did with the witches.
Will they do with body fat?
If you tell your body fat percentage
while they drowned them really tell if there are with,
she doesn't die.
She's a witch.
Sorry,
we were wrong.
I don't know if that's what they actually said,
but they probably figured out some way that she's still a,
which I think I probably would have been registered on the spectrum somewhere.
Fuck yeah,
you would.
Every comic.
I know.
Talking to Moshe Kasher yesterday about that.
We were talking about how,
well actually it wasn't him I was talking to about that,
but um,
it was another comic recently about how you,
we didn't talk about yesterday about like finding early on who the hell was it,
which comic was in here,
but finding someone early on and recognizing like,
hey,
it was motion.
We were like,
you're all fucked up in a lot of ways.
It's like,
dude,
do like get them right now.
All these impulsive,
crazy wild kids do and nutty shit.
Yeah.
You get them right now and go,
hey,
you're probably a comedian.
It was yesterday.
Yeah,
it was Moshe w.
But finding someone who can pay attention classes,
always mocking everybody.
Comerica park there,
there's hope for you really is like you like,
uh,
the number one draft pick in this,
in this class as far as like the standup comics trapped.
If I was going to come in,
you know,
as a,
I'm an expert on comedy.
Okay.
Stand up comedian a long fucking time.
I could come in and I could sit down with all these high school kids and who's
the biggest fuck up come here man.
Uh,
what,
what do you get in trouble for?
And the kid would start talking to me if I can get this kid to relax and start
saying,
well,
this fat fuck over here won't leave me alone.
You know,
it's like,
you know the in this bitch thinks his shit doesn't stink.
And meanwhile I know that she blew my friend.
She denies it.
And you,
you could find some crazy dude who is probably wild maniac like you can imagine
with Joey Diaz is like,
it was like a news 15 years old.
I'll probably stabbing people in class throwing bombs.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what he did?
Who knows what that guy did?
Yeah.
But if you could be there at that time and go,
hey listen,
you probably convenient.
Like you could be a great comic,
like all this other stuff.
It's not going to work out,
man.
That lawyer thing that your mom's pushing for,
shit ain't going to happen.
It's not going to happen.
You'll go crazy.
You'll jump off a fucking building,
man,
you're not.
You're a goddamn comedian.
That's the one I,
I,
there was no options in life when I was in college.
It was like,
you want to,
you want to go,
she'll carpet and east Georgia maq highs are going to hook you up with that.
Or like maybe I was never going to go sell medical supplies.
I wasn't smart enough to God.
I tried.
I tried doing the construction route so hard.
I couldn't work.
It was so hard.
It would drive me crazy.
I was doing it while it was still competing and man,
I did a,
I worked in my buddy Jimmy.
Hey we,
we did this,
a knights of Columbus Hall and it was all like a wheelchair ramp.
So for like two weeks it was just carrying pressure,
treated lumber and bags of concrete.
It was fucking brutal.
And up to the end of the day,
I had no energy to do anything.
I couldn't train,
I couldn't,
I didn't want to fuck.
I just want to sleep.
And then I'd get up in the morning,
the alarm would go off and I'd be like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
I can't believe I have to get up.
I'm so tired.
And you'd do it all over again.
It was every day it was carrying like who knows how many hundreds of pounds of
shit.
And I just thought of it,
I'm like,
this is some people's life man forever.
And they just look forward to Saturday and Sunday and then Monday comes along
and they bite down in their mouthpiece and they fucking just go out there
swinging and pick up those bags of cement,
carry him up that fucking ramp.
I'll never forget that week,
those two weeks that I worked for this construction company,
I mean it was a tough two weeks.
It was the summer.
It was hot out.
It was a tough job.
And ordinarily,
you know,
they're carpenters are ordinarily,
they don't have to deal with as many things like that.
Like they,
they build houses.
But occasionally there's a weird project,
like a giant wheelchair ramp at a knights of Columbus Hall.
It's a long ass fucking ramp required,
a lot of cement and a lot of pressure treated lumber and the truck pressure,
treated lumber,
the splinters getting your hand and just all I could think of is not feeling
sorry for myself at all but think,
oh like you could get stuck here like this is,
there's a whole lot of paths and options in life.
And I was,
I was on a really bad one and I was like,
Ooh,
you can get stuck here.
I mean,
it's a good honest living.
It's not as bad as a path of crime.
It's not as bad as a path of exploitation is not,
you know,
something morally bad.
But it was like,
Whoa,
this is going to be difficult and not very rewarding is going to feel terrible
and it does not going to pay you very much money either.
If you want to be a grunt,
if you want to be a laborer,
like it's tough work.
It's a real tough way to make a living.
And I remember knowing because of that that I had to find a way out and then
almost within,
you know,
a year or so I was doing standup but it was a part of the whole evolution that
that having that job was a part of my whole evolution cause I was like there's
no way this can't happen.
This I'll go crazy.
This will be a hellish life because when someone is just telling you what to do
all day and it's physically breaking and not rewarding.
W we're designed to want to play our,
our,
our mind wants to wander.
We want to figure things out and we're going to build things.
We want to,
we want to create,
we want to explore,
we're going to see new things.
That's what the human mind wants.
It doesn't want to carry bags of dirt up a fucking ramp all day bags or rocks
and dirt and fucking it's lumber all day.
Your body doesn't want that.
Your mind doesn't want that either.
Your mind wants to do with the shit.
You might want to go find some bugs,
but do you think,
do you think there are guys that really genuinely loved that job?
I don't know.
I would hope so.
Who knows how,
what people like and what,
I don't understand the grateful dead.
There's people out there that love him.
Oh,
I love the grateful dead.
They go.
I'm not saying you shouldn't love the grateful dead.
I bet this is a lot of shit I like to you don't like,
do you like Dwight Yoakam?
I loved Dwight Yoakam.
I love Dwight Yoakam.
Huh?
Johnny Cash.
Love Johnny Cash.
My dog's named Johnny Cash.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you a page on named something.
I'd think you don't like it.
Okay,
got it.
Do you like the smiths?
No.
You like the violent femmes?
Are you shitting me?
No,
I don't hate them.
I'm just not drawn to them.
Yeah.
But I like weird shit.
Like I lacked Neta and you know to and that as,
no,
he's just like a transvestite guy in,
uh,
in Toronto and he does these crazy youtube videos and they get like fucking
millions of hits.
I actually bought it as a vinyl because he's sold a vinyl.
So I'm like,
if I ever get a record player,
I want to have this guy shit because this guy doing it completely on his own.
He's up in Toronto,
he's apparently got a kid and his son like just not like it.
It sounds like full grown.
He's probably in his fifties at sky.
Oh really?
He does all of his own music.
He makes all of his own like really crude videos,
like super low budget.
Like some of them are just like a towel that's hanging in front.
There's him and that image dancing.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Oh,
I can see as a son not enjoying that.
That's just one of his more extreme videos.
But almost all of his,
no,
there's other stuff you don't have.
There's other stuff.
If you go to his youtube videos,
his youtube videos are kind of interesting.
They're like,
uh,
with those is real Niccolo tech and I think he like doctor and mom got into
Puffy nipples.
You chest got into puffy nipple.
How'd that happen?
It does take a pill and
bump your head.
I was,
I got a,
I was doing some,
I was doing something somewhere and I've walked by and the girl that was working
the front desk didn't have like a,
she didn't have like a bra on but her blouse definitely you could see like she
had it,
they didn't look like nipples.
It looked like little nouns on her tits and I just got caught off guard and I
was like,
what is that?
Like I've never seen them,
I've never been up close with them in my life.
It's amazing how much,
like whether you're pro or con,
how much that can change things like some guys like are really into big nipples
and then some guy's like almost no nipple.
So someone could look at the same breast and one guy be like,
yes.
Yeah.
Another guy bill you like I can imagine.
I think it's,
I think it's for when you're like 14 cause when you,
yeah,
what you see first I think sometimes sets your formation.
I'd never seen Puffy nipples and let me tell you something.
I might've been creeped out if I ever saw them growing up.
But man,
I got onto,
there's a tumbler page drunk perv in your,
in your latter years,
go to Buffy nipples.
Uh,
there's a a tumbler,
whereas like I'm glad you found me.
I'm a fan too.
Here's all the pictures I've accrued.
Don't go there.
I don't want to see that Jesus Christ.
So Strip people are so strange.
What's the weirdest thing you've seen on a girl?
A girl's body that you've never seen it?
Another girl that you were like,
what the fuck is this?
Nothing.
Like,
like a,
he never seen a girl with hair on her back.
No.
Like heroin.
Uracil yeah,
but that was standard back in the eighties man.
Yeah,
that was,
I don't see it at all.
White male and he's only my wife.
You make sure you don't see it,
right?
I don't like that whip.
Hey Brian,
let's get back to you to what
we were talking about to begin with,
which was this,
this battle that's going on with the men's rights and the,
and the feminist.
It's pretty fascinating cause I read this blog today where this,
all right,
here's the thing about all this stuff.
It's,
it's,
it's certainly important to be nice to women.
It's certainly important to be nice to men.
It's certainly important that we all get along and be cool with each other,
but there's things that happen when something goes down and these really extreme
versions of these ideas emerge,
and on the men's side,
the men's rights,
these,
some of these fucking
creepers,
these pieces of many people were so gross that one of the things that they're
saying is that if women fuck this guy,
that he wouldn't have gone this rampage and it's because all you stuck up,
bitches wouldn't fuck this guy.
Like this is what you created or you seeing,
oh yeah,
no bullshit,
no bullshit.
There's people out there and this world that genuinely suck and they genuinely
hate women and for whatever reason,
whether it's the programming they got from their mother,
whether it's the genetics that they got from their parents and their
grandparents,
I don't understand how personalities just totally created.
I don't think anybody truly does.
I think it's all guesswork.
I think there are occasionally though,
horrible examples of people who've gone through life and just been shit on and
fucked over and they've turned into monsters and so you'll run into him at age,
whatever,
30 whatever the fuck old that guy is.
It wrote that thing.
And you essentially have a woman hating monster.
Yeah.
That's the difference between feminism and the men's rights guys.
Because if feminism,
if they don't like men,
no one's gonna rape me.
You know?
If the women are upset with men,
you know,
if you wanted to similarly unhinged woman and she's bummed out about dudes,
it's very rare that she's going to resort to violence,
but a man who's like this guide,
it's like Zeus fucking stuck.
How bitches just fuck that doesn't really,
that doesn't work the other way.
It doesn't.
You don't need it.
I'm not going to hear that from women.
So the real problem with all this stuff,
it's not like that.
These men's right guys are all evil or feminists are all cons.
It's that we're doing,
there's two sides doing battle with each other for no fucking reason.
It's like,
what side do you want on the male side?
I'm on the woman's side.
How about just on the good human side?
Because if you're on the good human side,
all of it gets abandoned.
All of it.
It's all,
the whole battle gets abandoned.
It's like they forget that this is all about the people who died for nothing.
But what I'm saying is that like instead of like instead of like trying to like
attack each other and go back and forth,
that shit is never going to fix anything.
Instead of that,
instead of even engaging in that,
be like more proactive and support the good human being.
Ethics who support the good human being idea.
Just fucking be cool to each other and everyone who can't be cool to each other,
keep them the fuck away from me.
Keep them the fuck away from all of us are our issues aren't like men versus
women are issues are due.
She fucked up men first is conti women.
That's our problem.
That's our real problem in this life and the Douchey fucked up men victimize
more women than the women victimized men.
If a woman victimizes the man.
Here's the big one you always hear the big one you always hear is this fucking
bitch.
She schemed him.
She married him,
she pregnant,
and she took all his fucking money.
It was a plan the whole time so wide.
So what did she fuck?
'Em Yeah.
Then she did what he wanted.
She wanted money.
He wanted to fuck.
They got together.
She pretended to like him more than she did because she like money.
And the way to get him to give her the money is to potentially like some,
it's not fucking rocket science.
You're angry at that.
So you're angry.
A dumb guy with money got roped in.
Well guess what?
As smart as he was to figure out how to make all that money,
figuring out how to get good with human communication.
So we know when someone's just a hooker figured out how to figure out how to
spot.
Some chick has just trying to rob you because you're ugly and old,
but your richest fuck you thought she loved you.
Are you crazy?
Are you fucking crazy?
Do you have a mirror in your house?
And go stand in front of me.
Go smell your own breath.
You fucking creep.
You think she wanted to fuck you because you're hot.
Come on.
You had money.
She's got looks.
It was an exchange.
She got tired of it.
She left.
You didn't set it up right.
He did a bad job.
You got fucked over.
You lost all your money.
Start from scratch.
Stupid.
You're not a little kid born in Ethiopia with no feet.
All right.
I'm not,
I don't feel for those guys.
Yeah.
There's a big difference between a guy who's willing to just get in his car and
start shooting people because chicks won't fuck him and some girl who's trying
to con some rich dude in marrying her and getting her pregnant so she could get
a lot of money and fuck him over a divorce.
Who cares about that guy who gets the worst thing that can happen?
Child childcare and child support are the two ones that are really creepy
because some relationships they get so fucked up and again,
it's not a man versus woman thing.
It's an evil person thing,
like men will be accused of doing crazy shit to their kids that they've never
done anything but the wife hates the man so much.
Like maybe the guy fucked around on her with is some woman at work or something
like that and got her pregnant and I'm crazy and this and they're getting
divorced.
Women will say some evil shit.
She's like,
men will say some evil shit.
Men will make up things about their wife having affairs.
They'll lie about spending money,
the live,
they'll plant drugs on each other and then call the cops on each other.
People do that shit like that's one of the things cops look for in divorce
cases.
Like when someone calls in and says,
you know this guy a,
my husband,
he's,
he's using drugs.
I know he's using drugs cops ago.
Oh really?
Oh yeah,
he's using drugs.
You guys getting divorced or something,
you know?
Fuck yeah,
they have to.
They have to.
You have to win.
If you're a detective and you come and you're talking to someone,
they're like,
I found a bag of cocaine in my husband's underwear drawer.
Did you really?
Okay.
Are you guys getting divorced?
Yeah,
because if you're getting divorced,
hmm,
I'm,
I want to put you on a machine that finds out if you're telling the truth or
not.
Would you be cool with that?
The Fuck Outta here?
People are crazy.
Men and women.
Everyone's crazy.
No.
Was the women's side,
the women's side is that they have to deal with people like that all the time
and that men don't and that we should respect it.
But my point of view is,
is that,
I mean what I've already said,
but also that I think there's a lot of people that jump jump up when these
things happen and they look to make a big grand statement.
And I don't know if they're making a big grand statement because they really
think they're going to change things or because they want like moral Brownie
points.
Do you know those things where people do,
where you're like,
Ooh,
I think you're kind of being gross here.
I don't know why I just feel gross about this.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes people do,
they'll,
they'll talk about shit and you're like,
I know that you believe this,
but I also know you are loving all this like positive progressive ground Brownie
points are getting with this article.
This is like a bit of ego behind it.
That's quite distasteful.
Wait,
what was the article you read?
Was this one about Seth Rogan One?
No,
no,
no.
Did you hear about that one?
Yeah,
but this is,
no,
this is all about the murder.
All about the mass murder in Santa Barbara.
Yeah.
He had one about the mass party blame Seth Rogan on the murder murder in Santa
Barbara.
Oh my gosh,
girl.
I didn't read her her article per se,
but it was a feminist writing an article about Seth Rogan saying this is what
you get when you get,
when you make these male oriented movies like neighbors where the women are just
kind of like goody bags at the end of the movie and the women don't have a
voice.
And I think I'm,
I'm,
by the way,
I,
I'm never fucking listen to what I say.
I started this off by saying I genital warts.
No,
no,
no worries.
I general ward,
I was worried.
That's incredible.
Judd Apatow slam a movie critic,
a movie critic,
Washington Post's and horn.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Well,
you know,
it's funny,
but there's a lot of women that,
you know,
you go to the movies,
like here's when I,
when I really thought about it for the first time,
the first time I ever really thought about how weird it is and how biased movies
are,
and if I really do have white privilege,
it's definitely in the movies.
And this is why I went to see planet of the apes in a black neighborhood in
Philadelphia with my friend Tommy Jr and his girlfriend.
And,
uh,
we were,
what year is this?
This is recently the new plant of the apes.
Yeah.
A better story if it's 1976 no,
no,
no.
This is the real,
what year was a real printed names?
I think it was like earlier in the 70.
[inaudible] I think the shit was really early.
Um,
because black and white,
it wasn't,
it was playing on apes fucking,
no,
no.
Chad,
the albino monkey,
excuse me.
Anyway,
um,
so we were watching these previews for these movies and every movie was about
white people.
Every movie was about white people and over and over,
because you were in that room,
you're now seeing it.
You're like,
oh fuck.
Totally.
And then when there's finally 1968 was the original plan of the apes.
And when there's finally a,
um,
a scene where there's a black guy in it,
the black,
I was like a maniac.
I forget what the,
the thing was at the black guy was like,
oh,
complete over the top,
you know,
like this morning,
my fuck up crazy.
I don't remember who the book,
I think it was Tracy Morgan,
I think it was a movie with Tracy Morgan.
It was totally,
completely buffoonish and over the top.
And I was like,
wow.
And I never thought about it before,
but I was sitting there in that movie theater surrounded by nothing but black
people.
And I was thinking,
this is what is this light?
This is terrible,
this is annoying.
And then I realize what it,
you know,
I'd never even considered it before as a privileged white male,
I just would go to the movies and like,
Oh,
here's another fucking Tom Cruise movie.
Yawn.
Oh,
are you really in space,
Tom?
Are you really going to save the world?
Tom John,
oh,
here's Bradley Cooper.
He's taken a pill that makes them super smart.
John.
Oh,
here.
Scarlet Johannson.
They just injected her with something that makes her super smart.
Yeah,
I saw the trailer,
that scarlet to him.
What the fuck out of here?
It's all white people,
but if you're a it,
you know it's normal.
But if you go to the black theater and you're watching it with surrounded by
black people and you're like,
oh my God,
we're gross.
Yeah,
And we fucking,
we don't,
we don't make any movies for black people.
It's like,
have you listened?
Have you ever listened to opiate Anthony with your kids in the car?
Yes.
For like a half a second.
Can you realize it doesn't affect,
like,
I would never be get offended by opie and Anthony.
I don't even realize what they're talking about.
Like when I listened,
I just go,
oh,
this is great.
It's so entertaining.
And then your kids are in the car and you're like,
Daddy,
what's a Blumkin?
And you're like,
oh fuck,
I never gets that far.
I turned,
I turned on the car the other day and Anthony was screaming because she's,
hi,
I forgot what it was.
It what have been a best of,
I don't know what it was,
but it was just,
it was so ridiculous.
I heard the one,
one sec,
I'm sorry.
Using,
he's a cunt.
He's a Co.
It was,
he's a cunt.
Fuck.
What was it about,
goddammit.
And I heard that episode before,
so I wanted to hit the button immediately.
I immediately shut it off.
I'll listen to their old,
either old episodes when you're like,
when everyone's in Collin,
Patrice,
I listen to,
I'll listen to any of the ones Patrice is on.
I was listening to Patrice when the how,
and the other day was,
uh,
Anthony dressed up as a Nazi and Patrice
drop it and bombs left and right.
Great.
And He,
uh,
was they were trying to see who'd get picked up quicker.
A guy who looked like a Nazi or was a rapper or no,
or just a blind versus Nazis.
What it is.
Yeah.
But did he,
um,
did Patrice dress up like he did it go super ghetto.
I think he was just already black.
Oh,
here's the video.
Look,
get to Anthony's,
got a goddamn helmet on and they're picking him up before they pick it up a
trees and he's doing the hail Hitler thing and I like the arm up.
Yeah,
that's how he's got a Nazi helmet on
Nazi.
I stopped and I see,
maybe not see brother,
you chose not to over Nigga?
No,
no.
I remember who it was they were talking about Ellis.
About uh,
uh,
Jason.
Hello?
Jason Ellis.
Jason Nelson number and a few.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Yeah,
that's what it is.
That's whenever that one aired,
that's when they hit that button.
Fucking Christ.
My kids are just like,
fuck.
You could tell they just open up a door.
There's monsters inside.
Could chunk in the door just shot.
What was that Daddy?
Nothing.
It's nothing in there.
I uh,
I did the audio book and my book and I wrote an article,
a chapter about Patrice and I had to decide in their,
do I do Patrice has voice or do I just do a regular voice?
So in the,
so in when you buy the audio book and my book,
you hear me going,
it's not even a good,
even a good.
And I was like,
do I do that with all black people?
Like when I,
when will Smith talks too,
I make him like I did it,
I did it.
It's done.
Well Patrice is just so big with it.
He's so his,
you know,
his voice was so big and he was kind of almost have to do
cause yeah.
Cause you heard,
I was telling him on opiate Anthony,
but with the whole thing was that I did it again with cerebral palsy.
He didn't know she had cerebral palsy because I was drinking so much and Patrice
thought that was fucking hilarious.
And he kept saying
that is the worst version.
But it's like
Diaz impression and you have to do it right.
If you're going to say something that Joey said you,
you kind of have to say it again.
Everybody does.
If they say something as Joey,
you don't just say like,
if Ari has a joke,
you know,
like I might say it like as me,
I might tell you all are,
he's got this great new joke,
you know about blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Except if you're describing Ari mad,
then you'll do the
normal mumble.
You can't do that.
What was your will Smith voice though?
I'm saying
exactly.
Hey we exactly.
This is Coby Bryant voice.
I wrote the n word in the book twice and I was as white people saying it.
I didn't realize it because I didn't fucking really pay much attention to the
editing of it.
I just wrote them and then if,
if the publisher liked him,
I was in and I was like,
I read it and was like,
Oh shit,
I've got to say the m word.
And I was thinking for history,
I'll go down as saying the word and despite whether or not I've ever said it,
no one's got me on record saying it.
So I called my buddy Omar Dorsey,
who's on,
uh,
eastbound and down,
and I was like,
Hey,
can you come and read a passage of my book?
And he's like,
Oh,
I'd be honored.
Thanks.
Oh my God.
Oh,
he did?
He goes,
how am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to do this?
Like a white person?
I go,
post sound good that way.
Did it?
He's
like,
you know,
I love you,
but I'm getting you out of this one.
Yeah.
He's own up to it.
In the book itself,
book itself,
you would say,
well,
there's a question we'll word in this passage.
So I brought in a good,
I do.
Oh,
do you?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Fucking 16 hours to read my own audio book.
I was like,
oh my God,
I cannot read out loud to save my life.
16 hours.
How many hours is the actual audio book?
Three.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
I am the worst out loud reader and for like the first two chapters get mad if
you fuck it up.
Yeah.
The guy asked me like,
oh the first,
first chapter.
He's like,
hey man,
do you need glasses?
I was like,
no,
I just,
I'm not that good about.
And I was like,
I'll do it drunk.
Everyone wants to hear me do a drunk,
you can't fucking read drunk.
So then I described that day,
that day is all useless.
We had to go back and Redo it and then,
and then I was also like,
like I'd read a passage and then I'd go on and be like,
I'm like,
and then I'd expound on what I just read and kind of was like an,
I was like a podcast and that was fucking horrible cause that took like forever
and so that finally the guys like just fucking read it.
So I just read it towards the end,
but it gets better.
I think it would be better if you just read it and if you fucked up,
just comment on the fact that you fucked that word up and just keep going on
like that way people would,
they would get,
they'd get the book,
the whole book,
but they'd also get like spirits of you reading the book.
Like you separating yourself from the book while you're at it.
Oh yeah.
I mean they,
I don't know what it's going to sound like but I,
cause I,
I did acknowledge it.
I did what I did fuck up cause I'm a comic so I would work the piece as I was
like if I was on stage.
And did they keep that in or do they edit that stuff?
I think they kept some of it in but they couldn't have kept all of it in.
That's so weird though.
The day decide what gets left in and what comes out.
This whole to this whole book writing process has been vulnerable,
is fucked because you,
you really let go of it because it's a totally different industry.
Yeah.
I didn't,
I passed,
I had a book deal.
I was just writing the book and they were still giving these old wacky fucking
notes.
Just advice on like how I should talk about things,
what I should describe,
how I was like,
we're not,
this is not happening.
You know,
you're not involved in the creative process.
I gave them their money back.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Like they wanted me to essentially write my act down on paper and sell it as a
book.
And they're like,
well George Carlin did it and Jerry Seinfeld did it.
I was like,
ah,
that's nice.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not doing that.
I W I write different than I do standup.
It's two different things.
Like you can write when you're writing,
like just writing.
There's a way that you can express yourself that's unavailable if you're
talking,
you know,
it's,
it's why you,
the dragon dictate didn't work for me cause you'd talk it into this dragon
dictate and it would put it right into the computer,
like print it.
But it didn't work for me because it sounded spoken like it sounded like and,
and,
and a couple,
like,
one of the hard things for me was I,
I did that same thing where they wanted to,
all the stories I had told on stage or on podcasts,
I was like,
I can't,
I can't do that.
I can't just fill it up with that.
Yeah.
They want the stuff that they think they're going to sell.
It's not a,
an artistic thing.
It's like,
guess what dummy?
The same person that told those funny stories.
I can tell you other funny stories.
It's like we're not running out of funny stories here.
It's really fascinating.
And like their stories,
I had to put in the book,
I had to put the machine in.
I can't not write that in there.
And there's a lot of,
there's like the Will Smith Story.
I had to put it in,
but then I wanted to do the several polls.
One I wanted to do one where I met Ralph Sampson and when I was a kid I was,
I got off Thompson.
Um,
he was a basketball player and I was,
I went to school at,
I went to,
I was like in eighth grade I decided I really want to be a basketball player.
And so I went to Villanova basketball camp and Ralph Sampson came to speak.
And like the first night I got a concussion and the two best basketball players
got pulled out for drinking.
So the next day I had to sit out with too.
That's possible players and everyone thought we drank together.
So now all of a sudden I'm 15,
14 and everyone thinks I'm cool because I'm partying with the 18 year olds.
So Ralph Sampson comes,
I thought this define me.
Ralph Sampson comes up to give a speech.
He's like,
I'm here to talk to you about two things.
There's 5,000 kids on the gym floor.
He said,
we're talking about basketball and we're talking about discipline first.
Let's talk about discipline.
Who in here?
Parties.
And I was under the impression we were all gonna put our hands up,
but I was the only fucking person.
I just went trunk.
And he was like,
oh,
one person,
5,000 kids.
No one raised her fucking hand.
He's like,
how do you party?
I was fucking 13 I know how to,
I didn't,
I never partied in my life.
So all I said was hardy and he fucking lost it.
And 5,000 kids are slapping the gym floor.
Like,
Oh shit,
we're going to make an example out of you.
Party animal.
He's lost the room.
So he brings me up front to the in front of all the kids and he makes me stand
up and he puts a basketball behind my legs like this.
And then one on my arms like this.
And he's like,
we party hardy.
What?
We're going to party hardy today.
So I'm standing like this for his whole fucking hour speech with basketball here
and there.
And he's like,
and he keeps coming back to me.
And by the way,
I'm so in my head that I'm,
I'm have social anxiety disorder,
but I'm in front of everyone and I'm like being made fun of being mocked that I
wasn't listening to his question to him.
And he's like,
you think you'll ever party again?
I just said,
yeah,
and the fucking place went bananas.
They're like,
oh.
And he's like,
how do you party hardy?
I was like,
and I didn't know the answer.
I just was like,
with two hands,
fucking people are losing you think could do marijuana and now I'm killing.
I'm like,
I'll get to in college and these kids,
I left that gym and everyone wanted to talk to me.
Everyone's like party animal.
What are you doing and that you're still holding the basketball between your
legs.
Go home the whole fucking time.
Cracking jokes while I'm cracking jokes.
And how long did you hold the basketball?
An hour.
That's a long time by my cousin Abe almost brought him here today.
I should have,
I didn't even think about it.
My cousin aid was there at the camp even cause he's from Philly.
I didn't know anyone.
My cousin,
he was like,
I didn't even,
I didn't know you partied.
I go,
I don't,
I don't.
I just thought we'd all put our fucking hands up.
He's like,
yeah,
why would you put your hands up if you don't party?
I was like,
I want it to be cool.
So yeah,
so like so now and then everyone would come up and they'd be like,
party animal,
you partying hard.
I'd be like,
yeah.
But then I became cool at that camp and then I have friends and so I wrote that
story is a little longer and I gave it to them.
I go,
this is the best story.
This defines me.
And they're like,
ah,
I'm not really,
that's hilarious.
So it's all partying stories,
but it's like that's a hilarious story.
Oh,
thanks.
nutty.
That this could have possibly sent you on a path when you were that young.
Yeah,
13 years old.
I just,
I,
and it's all just wanting to be accepted.
I don't know.
Did you ever have one of those moments where you'd go somewhere and you didn't
know anybody?
Sure.
But you felt like everyone fucking grew up together.
Yeah.
That's a weird feeling.
I felt like that a lot as a kid,
but I thought that that define me because then I became the Po.
I became the party animal that kind of lived up to whatever I,
by the way,
I went to high school the very next year.
It didn't know anyone.
So I'm sure that kind of,
I was like,
well it worked in Villanova.
So yeah,
there's definitely different personality that develops when kids have to move
to,
right.
If they move from one spot to another spot,
they move more than once.
They developed this,
like there's this weird newcomer personality,
you know,
in every romantic kids movie,
the rebel that moved into town,
the new kid that you don't know of any think he smoked cigarettes and fucking
twilight style movie or even like karate kid.
He like move into some new town dude,
cry kid fucking the day karate kid came out,
it was my first day at tennis camp and so,
so I go,
I got to fucking can't believe I didn't write about this,
this,
I didn't know anyone.
I know anyone.
So then the,
these all the law very into camp.
I started meeting the cool kids and they're like,
hey man,
what are you doing today?
I was like,
nothing.
And they're like,
you want to go see karate kid?
And I didn't know anything about it and I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that'd be cool.
So like,
cool.
Meet us at mission bell.
That's where this place was.
My Mom's late picking me up,
we're late doing everything.
She drops me off to the movie late and I go in and the movie's already started.
I can't find any of the kids,
but I already bought the ticket and I already have popcorn and a drink and I'm
like fuck.
So I just go down and I sit down.
I've never seen a movie by myself that time and I just sit down and I keep
looking for him,
but I can't fucking find them.
But then the movie starts and it's a great fucking movie and it's a movie about
a loner kid like myself that doesn't know anyone and he's trying to break into
the new group just like I was doing a tennis camp and I really get involved in
it.
I get so involved in the movie that when he does the fucking crane kick and
kicks the guy,
I start bawling fucking crying,
thinking I'm Danielson.
I'm Dan.
In my head I'm like,
I feel like Daniel son,
the houselights come up and the fucking kids that were had wanted me to meet,
we're sitting directly like two rows in front of me and I've heard you weeping.
They heard me crying and I'm sobbing and weeping,
like sobbing,
like a fucking 10 year old cry,
like if you were 10 how'd that work out?
They turn around and they saw me crying and there were about to make fun of me
and they're like,
oh,
you got us,
you got,
we thought you
were crying.
You fucking with us.
You were sitting behind us the whole time.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
And I fucking walked out that movie.
I still to this day,
so you,
you had to fake that.
You weren't crying to fake that I wasn't crying and then we all hung out and
they're like,
you can just do that.
Make yourself cry.
I was like,
yeah,
wow.
Either credit or movie.
Yeah,
I've definitely cried in movies.
Like what?
Old yeller.
Oh,
even like boys in the hood.
No,
I didn't cry in that.
I cry,
watch movies with,
with when things happen.
A little kids.
Oh,
like a ransom.
And I give them watch that movement.
I couldn't,
it's not going to happen.
Yeah,
I can't,
I don't want to.
How about the time traveler's wife?
What's that?
That's a movie that I cried really bad at.
What is it about this dude who taught can time travel?
But yeah,
it's Eric Bana,
but as a kid,
I'm fucking out of here with that.
Hi.
Where they,
where they pitched that it was a woman.
She wrote it.
I told Dunkin about it and he goes,
did you read the book?
And I said,
no.
And he goes,
in the movie,
does he come back and teach himself to Jack?
Off I go,
it's not in the movie.
He goes,
and then they didn't follow the book and the book came back and taught himself
on a jerk off.
So you just kind of gain for himself who's a gay pat out to himself.
Yeah.
But he's only turned on the kids that looked like him.
Exactly.
But only,
maybe it's 14.
Hey everybody,
go to burp or protect common order.
My Book Go.
If you see in a bookstore,
buy it please.
And tweet me a picture of you shirtless reading in a Barnes and noble,
Tom Seger,
Tom Segura and Brendan Walsh.
Your book,
when you wrote it,
like how much,
how much input did they have as far as like what you could and couldn't put in?
Um,
probably 100%.
100%.
Like,
like,
uh,
like there was things they wanted in there.
There were things I wanted in there,
there were things they wanted in there.
So did you like have to meet in the middle?
Yeah,
I met in the middle.
Like it,
it is like a,
it is probably,
I think 14,
12 chapters.
It's probably maybe four chapters.
People heard the story like the machine and,
but uh,
but the rest of the one I got to,
but then there were ones they wanted to,
from like the article I told about the time I shit on a pizza box to win an
election.
Um,
I talk about,
uh,
me and my buddy Eddie took over this town one time that took over it,
but we told them we were writing a book like right out of college.
We told him we're writing a book for MTV about partying and then these,
these girls do a fucking insane party for us.
And they were all like,
fucking,
I mean it was,
it was like just out of a movie and then we all drank together and then I'm
trying to fuck this chick at like three in the morning and she's like,
she stops me.
She's like,
buddy,
I'm just doing enough to get in the book.
And I'd forgotten about the book lie.
So I'm like,
well,
book.
She's like,
you're writing a book.
And I was like,
I'm not writing a fucking book.
She was like,
that's the only reason we're here.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
the book.
So then I wrote at the end of that chapter,
honey,
I don't know where you are,
what your name is,
but you made it in the fucking book finally,
after all these years.
That's funny.
Yeah.
So it was fun,
but it
was,
it was,
I don't know.
I probably won't do it again.
Seems like a shit ton of work.
So fucking a lot of work for very little money,
but you've lived a fucked up life,
so it's probably important to document it.
Have you ever got an alcohol poisoning?
Have you ever taken it to the next one?
No,
I haven't.
I've never gotten alcohol poisoning.
But your liver,
you know,
talking about my liver,
you know they have those fog.
Voila.
They made it illegal in California.
Duck liver,
inflame duck livers.
They're delicious.
Then what they do is they take a duck and they put a feed are down its throat
and they force feed it and people hate it.
You know?
It's like,
it becomes like this horrible cruelty issue,
but meanwhile you can kill them and eat them still.
You just can't do that to their liver.
It's very strange.
And you,
you're not even supposed to sell it organic.
You can't have organic fog.
Why?
Which would mean you wouldn't overfeed them.
You just give them a lot of food.
Just have food around them all the time.
There'll be smaller livers,
but still delicious.
They don't even allow that,
which is crazy really.
It's like,
but it's still like you need the rest of the animal though.
Docs.
People eat ducks all the time.
The goose lake,
they had all that shit.
They ain't geese.
It can still eat it in Vegas.
That right,
cause I think I saw it in Vegas yesterday.
I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can get it in Vegas.
It's a to in France too.
I think we had it in France or animal cruelty.
Don't get me wrong,
but what's weird about the fog wall thing is there's ways of doing it ethically.
There's ways of doing it where the,
the the,
they actually want to get overfed.
Like they actually go around the feeder.
Like the birds are looking for it.
They want to get fed.
Really?
Yeah.
It's,
it's not necessary to hold their fucking neck like that and shove it down them,
but if you just give them a shitload of food,
you're going to have get a pretty good result.
It might not be as good as stuffing it down their throat,
but the idea is like banning.
It is ridiculous.
Like banning the shooting of a duck's liver.
Oh,
don't answer it.
We're on podcasts.
Fell.
I see where you're going to say I don't know.
Nevermind.
Go ahead and answer it.
No,
no.
He hung up.
Sorry.
He won't leave a message.
You though.
He will not leave a message and then he'll be upset when you don't call him
back,
but you don't know what it's about.
Well,
that's what he wants.
He just wants to see miss call on his phone and then he calls you back.
Anything else?
Yeah,
I texted him one time.
I tried to text him and he was just nothing.
And you're like,
well,
I texted,
I don't fucking look at that Shit Dawg.
I'm not looking at that shit.
Come on Bert.
Kreischer yeah,
he said he's got rules.
Yeah.
If you want to communicate with the Dawn,
how to follow the rule.
Fucking love.
Joey.
Joey has rules.
Yeah.
Like I said,
he's a perfect example of a guy who like had to be a comic.
You know there's a,
there's a lot of us,
man,
he's just got a guy that I'd like to see a book written.
What happened with that Tracy Morgan thing?
Cause Tracy Morgan says that that story's bullshit.
You know that story that you did and j more wind up doing for a while and
stopped doing.
He says it's bullshit.
Is it just lying?
He just doesn't want people that I knew it when I first told him that he was
going to say it the first time that story ever got out,
I was like,
here's one reason I want to tell it.
Number one,
Tracy Morgan,
uh,
we'll never remember that story.
He's never going to ever that night with me.
And he's definitely not going to fuck you.
I never thought he'd ever be like,
Oh yeah,
that's all true.
But Tony Woods was there.
So I mean,
and Tony Woods says it's totally,
woods remembers that.
Just like Tony remembers it a little differently than I do,
but we,
what we remember is now that's how you get out of paying the check.
And Tony,
and I've always said this,
and I've,
and I said this on your podcast,
first time I told it was,
and it's one of those things like I wanted to put this story in the book because
I wanted to clear up whatever rumor there was for good.
And that is when I,
when I got smoked that with Pete,
with Tracy Morgan,
he asks,
I remember saying,
what's in your weed?
And then he,
he said,
you smoked schermer whatever.
I want to ride over to Tony Woods.
And Tony Woods was like,
he's just fucking with you.
So like I've always said that I thought he was fucking with me,
that I didn't think I smoked PCP,
that he was just fucking with me the whole night.
So I'm like,
or not,
I don't fucking know.
But,
but I've never,
I've never said,
I've never said like me and him were smoking PCP.
What had happened was Pete,
the story he heard,
the story everyone had heard was jade Moore's version of it and he added things
to it.
Well,
it didn't happen to him.
So he didn't care.
He didn't have an attachment to the truth.
Right.
He,
you know,
so like in his thing,
I think it's were pretty much definitely smoking PCP all night long and they
were punching out car windows and having lightening bolt fights.
It was a much better story his way.
But my way was very attached to the truth of,
of I didn't know I had no fucking
can idea.
What do you think about that?
About taking a story and then adding a bunch of shit to it?
Like it's,
it's tricky,
right?
Because it does make it funnier.
Fuck yeah.
But it's not really,
it's like what,
where does it become art?
You know,
it's not,
it's like a weird collage of reality and paintings,
you know,
like dude,
a fake background,
like a real life,
but a fake background.
What kind of looks cool,
but like,
what is this?
This is a picture I go,
you telling me a story that really happened or are you just,
is this a like a fictional piece that you've created?
You know,
it's like one of those,
I was watching that fucking w movie.
Do you ever see the w movie?
Terrible movie.
Awful movie too.
We're just so clunky and cartoonish.
It's like an ABC after school special on the former president,
but while it's going on,
I was like,
I'm watching people pretend that these were the words that came out of all these
people's mouth in this order.
Like you don't know.
You weren't there.
I can't.
These people are alive still.
Like,
I can't watch this.
This is so ridiculous.
I can't watch it.
I I'm,
I'm not a,
I've always been very,
it's the problem with my storytelling is like the machine story is 100% true.
I can't really veered that much off the truth.
That's good though.
That makes you a good story,
but it makes it difficult.
Like I,
that's the reason I don't really,
I don't tell this Tracy Morgan story on stage just because when I tell it,
it's not very entertaining.
It says entertaining as it is,
but it's not like a great story.
There's big fucking Lowell's.
We were just hearing me give you facts of how,
what was next?
What happened next?
I wrote it in the book.
I would try to be fair to Tracy cause I didn't want,
I don't want people saying he smoked PCP.
Like I don't want him to have to defend that.
I would,
I would not like that either.
So I had to write it very fucking accurate to exactly what happened.
So that when,
if he does read it,
he goes,
oh yeah,
there were,
there had to be more than one night like that.
There had to be open about that,
which is why I was surprised he's,
well,
he said,
I will listen to him and NPR.
This is way before that story ever won a weird world.
Tracy Morgan's on NPR,
there was an NPR interview,
it's considered,
and he said,
he had said he'd never done drugs in his entire life.
Oh,
well that makes sense.
And I was like,
he said is yeah.
And so I was like,
okay.
And I saw on Reddit,
he was like,
I've always smoked my own weed.
I've never spoke PCP.
And then I'm like,
okay.
And in my head I was like,
well I just,
I don't,
those two statements are mutually exclusive,
but that's why I was like,
that's why I was like,
that's why I never wanted to tell the fucking story cause I was like,
he says he's never done drugs.
I've done them with,
I've smoked weed with him.
I think it's just like,
you kinda just let Tracy Morgan be Tracy Morgan.
Hey,
probably talk about that.
Does that story's done.
He said it.
It's done.
I would like to say nothing but good things about him from here on out.
I say in the book,
he is a fucking a well calculated smart guy who knows what the fuck he's doing.
It's funny shit man.
He's fucking hilarious too.
Makes me laugh all the time.
Bums me out that he hears my name and it and it fucking make and he's just like,
Oh man,
that fucking guy.
Maybe he doesn't,
you know,
maybe you'll see it one day or maybe meet him and he starts smacking me around
maybe.
And Red van has to save you.
Do you think you,
what do you think Brian would jump in front of a bullet for you?
You'd see my Jordans and be like,
damn,
all right.
Yeah.
I think Brian would save my life.
What do you think about when people would see your Jordans and have respect for
you and stop fighting?
Did I got some pretty sweet Jordans?
I don't think it works that way.
Good luck trying though.
Yeah.
What do I think of when you think about when the like,
like,
cause I read a lot of like comics,
books,
Comedians,
books.
One of the things I was disconnected with was when guys would just,
it seemed like they just would reinvent their history and just be like a lie
about it or maybe just not like,
not own up to things.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know.
You know,
I've only read a little bit of a few comics books.
I've never read a whole comics writing from start to finish.
I've read books on comics,
like a,
the Kinison books his brother wrote.
And um,
I read a little bit of,
um,
of Steve Martin's book,
but I get bored.
I get bored reading about,
you know,
I get it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I think that if I want to hear a comic,
uh,
if I wanted to read some comics writing,
most of the time I'd want to read,
you know,
what,
what's their thought process like what do they,
what do they think about things like what,
what,
what's happening in their life?
You know what,
um,
you know,
what do they think about the world that we live in?
Like what are their,
what are their thoughts that couldn't be condensed to a stand up act?
You know what I mean?
Like you'd rather hear someone's process,
write a book about their process or the way they think or the way they see
things as opposed to just like,
just,
just for tonic.
My mom moved in with my Stepdad who was a real piece of shit.
You know,
like,
I've heard those too many stories like that before.
You know,
that's not my
fucking,
I that that white guy in the black movie theater life where you go,
God damn white privilege.
Holy Shit.
What do you mean?
Like where you were talking about with when you were in the black movie theater?
Like I don't think I've,
I don't think I've had any of the struggle that anyone has in their life.
And I think that can cause anxiety to some people.
So you start thinking,
when's that going to happen?
When's the struggle happened?
When's the bad thing happened?
Like death or cancer or loss of a child or a kidnapping or a fucking school
shooting and your kid does it.
But you think about that shit all the time.
You're always thinking about like bad things happening all the time.
Yeah.
You just put that in the book.
How you're always thinking about bad things happening all the time.
You don't,
you don't think like that you can.
No.
You know,
I can.
I mean,
but I don't let it happen.
Yeah,
I don't,
yeah,
I just,
I stopped those thoughts.
Really?
Yeah.
They don't help you.
I know it's Paul.
I'm not stupid.
I know that people could shoot people.
I know that meteors can land.
I know the earthquake had hit at any moment,
but
right now it's okay.
Feel that.
Nothing.
So here's the problem that most of your time is going to be fine,
and everybody sits around waiting for the one moment when the fucking tsunami
hits instead of enjoying all the moments up until that point.
So what?
You're going to be bobbing around in the middle of the ocean,
gasping for air going,
I was right,
you were wrong,
and I was right.
We're all fucking dead.
You know when?
Then you're dead.
Too stupid.
But the problem is the now.
Right now,
that's what people are so terrified of and terrible at managing people who are
terrible at managing the constant state,
the state of right now.
So you're always looking for the future and you always worried about the past.
You're always looking towards some moment where it's going to all go bad and the
fucking sky's going to turn black and lightening bolts are going to go sideways
through the fucking town.
Everybody's worried about that,
but not enjoying,
not enjoying,
not things happening.
You're fine,
you're fine.
I'm fine.
One day I'm going to have cancer.
You don't have cancer now.
Okay?
And if you do,
you're still alive.
You know,
if you have hep c,
well you least,
you can say,
I have hep c when you're dead.
You can even say that
people are real bad at now.
The fucking,
so you're always worried about this and that and that and this.
You don't have to be okay.
If it happens,
it happens,
but right now it's not happening.
Concentrate on right now.
That's what people suck at.
People suck
at living in the present.
It's very,
very uncomfortable for a lot of people.
I think if you don't live in the moment,
you have a hard time writing.
Oh yeah,
I know.
I've been,
I've been in your own head.
Oh yeah.
Like Hey,
fuck you.
Just to go.
Seriously.
I just spent fucking three hours in bed worrying.
Can I feel my liver touching my my rib cage and then not living in like the
flame.
Does it have,
does that happen?
Does it really have your liver is probably enormous.
Oh,
am I fucking left side?
The pain is what?
Your fucking rights side.
It's on your right side because your liver is on your right side.
Yes.
I don't even bother googling and now you're upset when you get in with a left
hook.
Think about where you get hit with a left hook.
I've had pain here like in my heart.
It's below,
but it's like right here,
factory.
We,
your deck is dude.
I was not my liver off.
Fuck.
That makes me feel so much better.
Well,
it's probably your kidneys.
Your fuck.
I think it might be.
I think that might have kidney stones.
He breaking all those goddamn things I'm going to,
I need to fucking,
I would like to do one cycle of growth just to get my body back,
like just to get,
it doesn't work like that.
I just want to take one pill.
That brings me back to 20 everything.
Oh No,
no.
It doesn't help with healing.
Helps with healing,
but you're not going to heal the shit that's broken.
Like you can't just do a cycle of steroids and everything starts what you might
have wrong with you if you're seeing heal everything.
Like what do you got?
Do you need surgery?
I don't know.
My back is all fucked up.
Fucking bulging discs and shit.
Yeah.
You know you got to take care of yourself son growth.
I was just like,
yeah I thought maybe if I got on growth I get inspired to take care of it.
Count how often you work out a lot.
I just started doing a lot of core and like the yoga where you do like double up
when you do the hold the pose and then you pump it.
Um,
but I just got these arm bars and my back cause I was like I'm going to fucking
fix my core hanging out with Stan.
Hope I think I have a hernia is too.
I'm fucking,
let's just do,
just open a bottle of fucking whiskey.
This is a fucking,
I'm what's matter what?
Nothing.
Trying to get whiskey now.
I've had three days of honesty,
sincerity that I thought I could feel my liver now.
No,
it's on the other side.
You have any idea what to fucking,
do you ever go to the doctor once a year?
I'll go next week.
And what you fucking gearing up for that.
What's the thought process behind that?
Do you ever worry that you might be giving yourself something but thinking about
it all the time?
I think about that too.
I,
uh,
I do,
I definitely prepped for the doctor.
Like I don't go in raw like I fucking have a week of by,
but I just started not drinking on planes.
That was my biggest thing was just started,
just started.
So every time you take a plane flight,
you would get hammered every time.
Wow.
And that,
I was like,
that's not that I can genuinely feel that.
Does anybody ever reached out to you?
Like a doctor drew type dude,
Dr Joo,
I talked to doctor about it.
What did he say?
He's like,
it's bad
while you're,
you're,
you're an alcoholic.
No,
no,
no.
It doesn't say I'm an alcoholic because here's the other thing is that I can
totally not drink,
but I couldn't.
The thing is I couldn't not drink on planes.
I really genuinely could not,
not drink on planes.
Like I got to a place that if I was on a plane or if I was getting on a plane,
I had to drink and I would be physically ill having to put alcohol in my mouth
at like for a six in the morning flight on a Sunday and you're just like,
I don't fucking,
I like gagging going,
this is disgusting by need to calm down because I'm freaking the fuck out.
It's weird that that's the one public place where it's totally acceptable to get
fucked up.
Yeah.
I mean the plane is the one public place where they're the people that work
there who are also involved in making sure you're safe,
serve you booze.
I mean,
how weird is that?
Like it's totally,
I mean,
would you like a Mimosa and they all see you and then you want to double that
always doubled for half the price.
That's the right at the first thing they ever hear in an airport.
Can I get a jack on the rocks?
Would you like a double for half the price?
Sure.
Done.
Double for half the price.
The second one.
Second one's hot half.
Wow.
Yeah.
But they're trying to get you fucked up so they can sell,
sell booze,
not people who are scared.
Why isn't there the junk or on the plane now you never see like the [inaudible]
or there are,
oh they are if you fly as much as I do,
you see aggressively drunk people and the arguments on planes,
which is really uncomfortable.
The problem is as a guy who drank on planes,
I was never,
I was always well below the radar.
Like I never caused drama if I never pushed it when it came to drinks,
if I felt like I had ordered too many I would stop and,
and I was well aware of it.
And then when you see it and then when we went to Hawaii,
like recently,
like a few weeks ago,
Leanna came off the road a fly in from like,
I don't know where it was by flying in and I'm coming in hot.
Like you can tell like I'm,
I've been drinking on the plane a lot and I'm a flying like every other day and
Leanne's like pulled the plugs.
He goes,
no booze on this trip.
And went,
what?
She goes,
no booze on this trip.
You're gonna hang out with the family.
You're going to connect with the family.
And I was like,
this is a problem in the crusher household.
I said,
no.
okay,
I can do that in Hawaii about on the plane.
She goes,
no booze on the plane.
See if you can do it.
And so I was like,
can I take a Xanax?
And she was like,
yeah,
Jesus,
Fun and so much.
But you take a nap.
I don't have that brain,
Brian.
Oh my God,
I don't ever,
if I have something to do,
I would never sleep through an alarm.
I love,
I literally stay awake thinking I got to wake up in the morning.
Like I'll,
I'll sleep half,
half.
Like,
uh,
like I got an early,
I don't want to miss my alarm.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I don't,
why didn't she say you can take a Xanax if you're trying to stay sober to me on
a plane,
I'm getting Xanax puts it gets you fucked up right now it's very mild.
And I talked to doctor drew about it because I was concerned.
So I was like,
I don't want to take,
be taken Xanax.
He goes,
one,
what you're taking,
what I take is what I would take to fly now.
So I'll take it to fly and it's all only time I take it is half a milligram.
He was half a milligram.
Your body processes it that like less than a shot of Tequila.
Hmm.
He's like,
it's that
healthy for you.
He said the problem is,
I'll see for liver wise,
I'm talking about it was not healthy for me.
It's just not bad for you.
It's not bad for you.
Okay.
Um,
and I take it healthy.
It's not healthy morning with their fruit.
It's a fruit salad and Xanax.
Oddly enough,
it does take your blood pressure down.
It makes me calmer and it allows my food to process more efficiently.
Imagine they found a Xanax,
like does shit like that.
It allows your body to process things better.
I find I learn better when I'm on Xanax.
Dude.
Have you ever had a,
have you ever had the ADHD medicine?
The,
what?
Is that Adderall.
Adderall.
No,
no.
We talk about it all the time though.
I know.
I know it,
dude.
He's got a problem.
I know.
It's a couple dudes who have a problem with it is in fact,
yeah.
One that's got a real problem with it though.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
You know,
never tried it.
Scared.
Really not interested.
Oh,
it's,
you can focus like it.
My chat a whole lot to do anything that it speeds me up,
man.
I'm trying to stay calm.
You and sandy says,
I don't want that either.
I'm fine.
I smoke a little weed.
Weed is better for you.
We'd is better for your liver then Xanax.
I'm not interested in those pill highs,
man.
I'm,
maybe it's a good one.
I don't know.
But those pill Heizer they're creepy to me.
I don't want to enjoy it.
I like it.
And then be looking to support some pill,
high company and,
but you know,
it's really hypocritical on my fault on my part because what is Xanax?
It's just technology.
Somebody figured out how to isolate some compounds that do something very
particular to the human body,
like why would I be against that?
I love science.
I love the idea of the constant innovation and that's what that is.
Someone figured out a way to alter human neurochemistry.
I just don't trust me.
That's why like I said,
things like Adderall,
I'm like [inaudible] not for me.
I'm too crazy.
What if I like it?
What if I like and I started,
I have really good self control,
but if I started taking Adderall and getting a lot of shit done,
I could see me justifying taken Adderall a lot and getting shit done.
What time to get shit done and just fucking just fucking ramp up with some
Adderall and start rebuilding a wing of my fucking house.
If that's what you do.
Yeah.
I'm not interested in that.
It's like spinach.
Yeah.
I'm trying to stay calm.
I thought I thought it Adderall would be great to write a book.
I bet it would.
I've heard of people snorting Adderall or a friend who's a author,
allegedly,
he's just snort Adderall.
And uh,
his wife got mad at a beach,
you snorting Adderall.
And he's like,
I'm just trying to fucking write the book.
She was like,
you're fucking snorting it.
He said,
well that's the most difficult.
I don't care.
Just take it to take it and wait an hour.
Do you have to fucking snort it like this big Duke had?
He's like,
what do you,
what do you care about the delivery method?
She's like,
I'm not having this argument with you.
Don't start drugs in my house.
I told you my dad was doing that speed for a long time.
Your Dad was doing speed.
I told you a long time ago.
It was probably three years ago.
But yeah,
he uh,
he was,
the doctors prescribed it.
Oh.
And he was taking the pill and it was,
and he didn't realize it was speed and he was just like,
I'm getting so much shit done.
And,
and you said it is the other phen phen phen was one was a [inaudible] was a fan
fan trim spa.
What does that stuff,
they ain't in Nicole Smith Eia Sta.
So didn't that what stuck they got,
they pulled a lot of that shit off the market.
Right.
Like rip fuel,
you can't buy that anymore.
Right.
I have a bottom of terms.
Spotlight.
Nicole's son died in the waiting room.
Overdosed in the waiting room at her deathbed.
Daddy.
Really?
Yeah.
Like she was overdosed and dying and then he overdosed and died or wait,
maybe wait,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
He died.
She had a baby and he died in the waiting room for the baby.
Oh God.
Man.
That fucking,
yeah,
it's not a good role model.
That and Nicole,
is that really going to teach you the ins and outs of life?
Character Development?
No.
Fucking ah,
so crazy.
I have a,
uh,
a family member that's got the problem with the oxys.
Oh,
we have lots of family members with those guy was totally normal.
Got Injured at work,
back problems,
just like bad,
lower back.
Dr Hooks him up with the pills.
Boom.
He's off to the races now.
He's a fucking complete total loser and can't keep a job.
He was all,
I'm knew that kid from early age,
it's always worked,
always been responsible,
you know,
cat,
a little nutty but always on the ball.
Got Things done.
All he needed was that getting hooked on those auctions.
That was his checkout.
Donesville pain pills are so fucking good.
I can,
I can imagine.
I can totally imagine.
I just never done them.
You don't like after your surgeries with your back?
Nope.
Well I did one with one surgery,
my first ACL surgery where they uh,
it was a very particularly painful way of doing it because a,
they did what's called the Patella tendon ligament,
a PCL.
Um,
they take the um,
the PTL,
um,
and they take a slice of it.
Like say if your Patella tendon is about that wide,
they might take like a third of it and that Strip,
cause you did Patel attendance really big.
You don't need that to be that big.
It's sort of over designed.
So they take a piece of it,
then the open you up and then they screw it in and they create a new ligament
with your own body and then your body accepts it immediately because it's yours.
But you have a screw in the bones of your upper and lower leg and you have this
ligament that's a part of your Patella.
The whole thing is fucking inflame and swollen.
It's pretty painful.
And they gave me one of those,
we couldn't figure out which one it was,
viking or percosets.
But uh,
I took one and I felt so fucking dumb.
I just was like,
just dumb.
Just doll.
My mind was shot.
I was like,
I'd way rather deal with the pain and the pain was excruciating.
It was,
I would get up,
the real pain was when I would lie there,
um,
on the bed,
like watching TV.
And then when I would get up,
when I put my foot on the ground,
all the blood would rush to my knee and it was like laser beams and razor blades
and sand and hot lava and does
the whole knee was on fire.
So that was like for a few days,
but that was better than the Vicodin dude.
We take fucking him for Sunburns,
Florida.
If you've got a really bad sunburn.
He goes,
if I get in his sleep,
okay,
Laura though,
man,
have the pain really shut pain off.
Why?
Because you can deal with it.
But I go,
people fester on pain.
I mean,
there's some excruciating pain.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean it's not all pain is not the same,
but the pain of like surgeries,
like,
like when I had my nose fixed,
I had a septum
this.
Well before I knew you and I saw,
didn't you do a video of you training it?
Yeah.
Tom's correct.
What time's the girl was in the answer.
Yeah.
We did a video because,
um,
I wanted people to know that it was no big deal because I was terrified to doing
it and I waited a long time to do it.
My nose was broken when I was like five.
I fell down a flight of stairs when I was five.
And like my whole life growing up,
my nose was fucked from everything from sports,
from martial arts.
It was fucked.
It was just,
there was nothing in there,
but just,
it was just a blocked up by scar tissue.
And so when they opened it up,
they actually made it a little wider.
Like you can actually,
I can tell the difference in pictures.
Look,
looks wider because he opened it up and cut the turbinates.
They're these like these things inside these lumps.
He cut it and he put these plastic splints in there and stretched it all out.
And then these other,
uh,
these sponges get stuffed into the,
the holes like beside the plastic splints.
And so the sponges stay in your nose for,
I think it was like a week.
I don't remember how many days the sponges come out and then two weeks later
they pull the plastic strips out and you just got this,
oh,
it's this,
is this you cleaning it?
This is me.
Like right after the surgery I had to clean it with a waterpik.
I would use a waterpik
skinny Tom Ziglar is,
it's like a baby.
Okay.
Barrick time,
poor little child.
He gained a company,
parents.
So,
uh,
you will you use this waterpik
can you pump it up clean?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
My operation
twice a day or I take some water.
Special nostrils attachment.
That's like a Neti Pot,
right?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Steroids.
I was blowing mads sons if photos you sent us picture messaging back.
Yeah,
I put on a,
I put them on Twitter.
Some of them,
some of them were so big,
the boogers was so big.
It looks like I faked it.
It looks like I,
I brought in some CGI boogers.
I showed one at a time with the airport and he started heaving.
He started mu immediately
was hurling.
Yeah.
That was um,
but they gave me all kinds of shit they gave me prescriptions for.
He gave me prescriptions for two different pain pills.
And I remember after the operation,
walking around my house going,
I'm fine.
Like I don't need anything.
And um,
my mind was like,
do you want to take the prescription and stuff?
And I was like,
I'm not taking shit.
Like,
I'm fine.
what is everybody fucking complaining about?
It was nothing.
It was literally nothing.
It was like,
oh no,
it feels slightly uncomfortable in my nose.
But people tweak,
they start freaking,
I mean,
they caught the turbinates,
they stuffed it,
they cut out all the scar tissue,
the whole deal.
And I was like,
nothing.
You know,
it's just like a little little achy.
Like so what?
It wasn't anything serious.
But a lot of people are like any little slight uncomfort feeling any slight
discomfort like,
yeah,
maybe.
I mean lane pills,
it's just like a door that just opens up and gives you a free ride.
Just a free ride to start doing pills.
You know,
a free ride.
Just,
yeah,
come on.
You got a free ride.
Very injured.
You need medication.
Mr Kreischer recursion and next thing you know,
you're lying in bed with your feet propped up and you're in fucking Xanax.
Land Du du,
Du du Du du Du pump pump pump him.
Why do you like the dead?
Explain that.
When I fly lately I've been listening to the dead.
Just a nice,
you don't have to worry about it.
It's a,
it reminds me of college.
It reminds me of like a time when I literally lived in a microcosm of just
having a great time when you could tap out,
get off the grid.
Like I was like,
like it's a reason I cut off the grid.
Yeah.
You mean like
you can't like can't really tap out as easy as I could back then because you're
not all I have is one phone and it was in my house.
Oh,
you could,
you could literally get a bag of weed and with some frisbees and just be gone
from the world and you,
and you were in the moment.
I was really in the moment back then because you were like talking to your
people and no one was going into their pocket looking at their hands.
I was talking to this lady today and I was dropping my daughter off at school
and she goes,
wouldn't you love to be their age again?
She was an older lady and I said,
I don't know.
I said,
I think,
uh,
I think the world is way more complicated now for them than it was for us.
And,
uh,
she goes,
oh,
you got that right.
And so I leave,
I say goodbye to the little one.
I get in the car and I started driving off and as I'm driving,
that's all I could think about.
All I could think about is how crazy it would be to be a baby today to be a baby
today.
And you know,
you're going to have to grow up.
Why?
By the time you're in high school,
there's going to be mind to mind communication.
You now when you're going to know everyone's going to know everything about
everybody,
you're going to have some of the weirdest technology that's just,
it's just done computers and drawing boards right now,
but it's going to all exist.
It's going to be the same.
Yeah,
within 18 years.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
The world is going to be an 18 years and these kids are growing up and
experiencing it.
I would want to be 10 years less at all the way.
I
don't,
I don't want,
here's what I be honest with you.
I think Twitter and like and like email.
I think it's,
I think it's the cause of depression with a lot of people.
I look at Facebook and how much people share on there.
Like I was,
I'm not gonna say anyone's name.
I was following this girl who's talking about the breakup of her marriage and
the fact that her husband was kind of having a hard time with it and that he was
maybe like acting inappropriate or he came by and he asked to get some of his
stuff and she was sharing all of this on Facebook with all these people and all
these people know her and her husband.
But I mean,
but if you look,
I mean all people do is talk about tragedy on Facebook and like,
it's like they're sharing,
it's this,
it's this want to be famous.
It's this one that everyone has to put,
make their lives public.
And it's so,
it's not everybody,
man.
It's not everybody
dummies.
There's a lot of people that aren't doing that.
When I see people like fighting on Twitter,
like relationship fights on Twitter.
I stopped talking to both of them.
Not talking to either one of you dummies.
You doing,
you're,
you're talking shit about each other on Twitter.
What are you trying to hurt each other's feelings?
Well,
you fucking 12.
You're a man in your thirties and you're fucking tweet negative shit about your
ex letting the world know how she would come home at three o'clock in the
morning.
Shut the fuck up.
You're so fucking write about that.
You weak bitch.
You're the problem.
Yeah.
You look at people getting in fights on Twitter and you're like really
disgusting dude.
Trolls.
But I would never,
I've never engaged.
I've never responded.
I never replied.
I don't fuck around like that.
I just have you say something negative in me.
I don't block you.
I just,
I put it my memory,
my memory bank.
Yo,
it's fucked up,
man.
Um,
one of the things that people were talking about when they were talking about
this kid in Santa Barbara that went on this fucking killing spree was him being
rejected.
And this guy on this message board that I go to was talking about how he knew
this kid in high school that was like that and he knew them all growing up and
he was just not a good looking guy.
And he started out pretty normal,
but people were mean,
knew him and all this rejection like all throughout his life.
It's just constant state of rejection,
rejection,
fucking people pranking him.
It's just an ugly dude.
And then he was talking about how by the time it got to high school,
the kid started getting dark and one of the girls in their high school and
attractive girl died in a car accident and he was laughing and he was mocking
her and they were like,
Holy Shit.
And that's when they realize like,
wow,
this guy has become a monster.
Like he's,
he's mocking that this girl died.
It was pretty fascinating because here's the deal with a guy like this guy who's
a Santa Barbara killer,
like he was a handsome kid.
Like if you look at him,
he's not an ugly kid by any stretch of the imagination.
What was he small,
whatever he was.
I mean he's maybe,
look,
Tony Hinchcliffe is small.
Nobody.
Tony's got a great personality and his hilarious,
you know what I mean?
And people love him.
It's like you could be a tiny little person and girls will still Iq this,
this guy.
There was something obviously like really,
really wrong with him mentally,
but it got me thinking about like a person's looks like that's a motherfucker
man.
Like if you're born fucked up,
like if you have a diff,
something deformed or if you just have a weird skull,
your fucking face looks weird.
Like your whole life,
people are going to like,
Eh,
eh.
The normal reaction that people have to you is like,
eh,
this norm.
It's like,
it takes them a while to come up with the warmth,
but the,
the immediate react,
nothing can be done about that.
Like a,
that is a genetic motherfucker.
You know,
you're talking about like a lottery.
If you're a woman and you're six foot three,
you know,
and you waste 300 pounds,
your fucking heads,
enormous shit.
You know,
there's women out there that align.
And then they're just like,
you know,
everywhere they go there's by no fault of their own,
they just got this wacky genetic fucking roll.
The dice,
cleft palates,
cleft palates I the thalidomide babies,
there's a,
there's a Wa there's a organization called Operation Smile that I think that
I've donated to in the past,
but I would do anything for because exactly what you're saying is what they fix
that for like a hundred bucks.
It's a,
you fix a cleft pallet on a child.
A child knows why would anyone,
no one deserves to go through life looking at,
I mean I'm just saying,
but looking like a,
like a monster,
like and if you have a cleft palate is pretty aggressive.
So like I look at that operation smile dude.
That's how fucking great place to present money.
Yeah,
you're going to send fucking money go.
That's,
you can fucking change a person's life for ever by letting,
by gifting them the surgery.
I think we're just starting to realize as a race,
the human race is over the last x amount of a hundred or thousand years.
We're just starting to realize that we have to kind of take care of each other
better.
Sis,
it's like,
it's all there.
There's,
we're constantly dealing with competition as well though.
And when the competition comes up,
that's when people get this fucking attitude.
Like this guy who was angry at this,
at all these women,
you know,
this,
uh,
this one that my friend,
online,
it talked about,
when you think about that guy,
like that's almost like a guy who was in competition and kept losing over and
over and over again and hated the competition.
Like in a lot of ways it's very similar.
You know,
like the hated the other side.
He hated those.
Like human beings have got to figure out a way to stop that.
Like once we figured out a way to work together and stop competing about shit
like that.
But the problem is there's always gonna be people that have just massive,
unfair advantages.
And that's one of the things that this kid was talking about.
Like with,
when he described men as brutes said,
girls just wanting to have sex with a big muscle bound.
Brutes,
you know,
like in his mind it's like he could never be a brute.
He just was always shut out of that.
If a girl wanted that,
it's like dammit.
Like it didn't make any sense.
It didn't make any sense.
You add that to the fact he was a fucking psycho
and then boom.
Whereas most people that are,
you know,
unfortunately built or unfortunate looking or how unfortunate genetics or
whatever it is,
they just,
they just deal,
they just have to deal.
And so the difference between a guy like Ryan Reynolds who walks through this
world,
like on a fucking magic carpet of gold,
you know,
he's a beautiful man.
Just,
yeah,
everywhere you see them,
you want to smile babies,
I'll smile at them and then,
you know,
fill in the blank,
figuring out your guy.
No,
no,
you're good.
Look,
yeah,
but it's not regular looking human being.
I mean,
that's why I believe if formed my personality,
whatever soft shoe I know how to do to get people like me,
it was because I didn't have the,
I didn't have the fuck in the jaw line that maybe like,
like one of my buddies had that like I have,
I have a buddy I wrote about him book as my Buddy Jeff Hartley.
He's like one of the fucking best looking guys.
Confident big fucking hands.
Like just everything about him is just bigger and,
and,
and he knows how.
And I guess at a young age you realize worlds cruise and easy for you and you
learn how to just be like,
you learn how to fucking fill the shoes.
And just,
and he's,
I never had that,
so I had to learn how to talk to chicks.
Like,
like not spit game but be like,
you know,
be funny.
And I think at four,
my personality,
yeah,
without a doubt.
Most funny dudes are funny because they had to make checks laugh.
Yeah.
You know,
that's why good looking guys are not usually very funny.
Harley's funny,
but he's funny too.
A bunch of dudes and a dude way.
Not like,
yeah,
lot of times.
And not even that,
you know it's like hot checks.
So a lot of hot chicks that are really good at stand up.
Yeah,
they don't have to be me.
How many hot chicks are really good does they're like 20 of them.
Schumer?
Yeah,
Schumer.
There's a few other ones.
I know a few other ones I always find when the chicks funny,
I want to fuck her.
Whoa.
Easy part.
And I'm not saying it like about Amy.
No,
I mean I always,
I used to tell Amy that.
I know,
I know I could have sex with her if I wanted to.
And it would always be like,
you're fucking out of your mind.
And that seems like a rude thing to say.
No.
I told her we were doing this so reality bites back.
I was like,
I could totally have sex with you.
And she was like,
no you couldn't.
And I was like,
no,
I know who I can and you're in my soft spot.
Like I know where she was like,
no,
you really can't.
And I go to Amy trusts me,
I could get,
you know,
what did she find this amusing?
I've known Amy for a very long time.
So you waited a couple of weeks.
My wife by the way,
like yeah,
Amy used to stay at our house when we'd go to on vacation,
Amy would use our house and come out to La and do like meetings and stuff.
It's cool.
Yeah.
Good friends with my sisters.
No Shit.
Yeah.
And so like when I,
when I was on the road,
if I was over on the road and were are,
we were together,
she'd be like call.
Like I was important.
One time she calls,
she's like,
we're fucking party at tonight.
I've been on a tour,
we're partying.
And my wife's totally like four in the morning.
I'm in a hotel room with Schumer and a bunch of people we don't know.
And my wife's like,
and I had to tell my wife and she's like,
oh cool.
Telling me.
I said Hi.
Tell her to keep her head on shoulders.
His fucking big world makes,
you know,
Amy kind of blew up all at once.
Real quickly,
you know?
And so,
and my wife knew her before that.
So your point is,
I have no fucking idea,
John.
Sometimes I talk to you and I find myself,
I can't stop speaking while you're kind of umbrella Mr Bert Kreischer.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
Nothing wrong with it.
No.
Yeah.
Just your style of communicating.
I talk a lot in quickly.
Well then also like when you talk a lot in quickly,
like anybody that's entertaining like that,
like every now and then you're gonna run into like a sentence that doesn't have
an end.
And,
uh,
so yeah.
Amy was,
Amy is my friend
ended that way.
Like a,
so a,
yeah,
Florida.
So it's hard.
I wish I had those smoke bombs dropping in front of me and just walk away.
Yeah.
People would tell bad stories do that way too much.
You know,
like if it's just occasionally,
but in the art of storytelling when you have to go,
yeah.
Well,
uh,
so,
that's a,
that's Detroit for you.
Unless it's really funny.
That's really something you should shy away from.
If you want people to pay attention,
you're fucking stories.
Like I think the lesson here is
some people are brutal,
man.
Some people would just give you fucking ear beatings and never realized that
there were,
uh,
there was a dude the other day in a green room.
I step in and uh,
we're talking,
me and this other guy were talking for like two minutes and going back and forth
and someone brings up some subject that this dude had some personal experiences
and then it becomes his show.
And so for the next five minutes,
he's telling this fucking long drawn out story and I can't take it anymore.
And Brian was there.
I can't take it anymore.
So I had to leave the room.
I just got up and left.
I'm like the middle of the story.
I just,
just slowly like moving over and still am I,
I'm not gonna do this.
You're not going to beat me down.
And there was no point to it.
Zero,
none.
And I knew it.
I knew it from halfway into it.
And it was all these details and it was just like,
oh,
it was that fucking crime was a crime against humanity.
I just got out of there.
I was like,
I'm not going to be rude,
but I'm not going to listen.
You can't make me listen to this.
By the way,
it's my green room.
All right.
I'm the one that's performing.
Hearing he wasn't even performing there is stepped in and fucking beat me down.
Was it your colleague?
Whatever,
whatever.
What's crazy is that he thought it was like someone in that moment thinks that's
their moment to shine.
You know what?
It's not even that dude.
This is a problem with comedians.
Some comedians,
they don't really have conversations with you.
They just talk and sometimes they don't.
They don't absorb like what the other person is saying.
You know,
like if you,
you might tell your story about how you didn't know that you're a girl had
cerebral palsy because you were so drunk off that you might tell that story
and they're just waiting to tell a better story about a better drunk girl or a
battle or better situation with the fucked up.
They're just waiting,
you know,
they're like almost he Dunbar Dunbar,
you don't worry.
Did not like,
like they don't have any questions for it.
You're like,
wait a minute,
wait,
wait.
You didn't know she was drunk.
There's none of that.
It's like what may talk glad maybe cog and those guys are goddamn exhausting.
They're waiting for the moment where they hear the bell.
Like your turn.
That was this guy,
right?
Yeah,
it was.
It just needs to be edited.
Like his whole story.
It was just like,
I just wanted it to go,
you need to edit it.
You know,
throw in a little bit more interesting.
Peeks into,
totally took over our conversation and it was like seven people in the room.
There's so many people in the room with like all of us had to,
just like we had no other choice.
We were supposed to stare at this person and he wasn't a good story.
It was brutal.
Yeah.
That's why I have to limit your,
your engagements.
You have to limit the type of people that you communicate with Mr. Crusher.
Every now and then you're going to find someone who's a fucking white belt in
ear beatings and they just,
they stumbled through it.
They pull hamstrings.
They just kind of can't.
You can't.
You're the kind of person that just goes,
yeah,
like,
like you don't allow people to take liberties with you.
If someone's like,
hey Joe,
can I take a picture with you?
I want to like,
uh,
I want to grab your face.
You'd be like,
no,
it's not going to fucking happen.
I definitely am like,
all right,
grab my face.
Why do you let them
come out to Philly this week?
Going to be like,
let me grab your fucking face.
It's going to happen.
No one would say that.
It's going to happen for sure.
Do as you're writing that down.
Now we're opening up the notes APP on their phone.
I always get,
Hey,
can you take your shirt off?
Can I get his picture with your shirt off?
You're going to be here,
Brian.
What does that,
what do you get Dylan?
He's grabbing my fucking phone.
Are you taking a picture in the middle of the podcast?
You Fuck Jesus Christ.
20 minutes late and stops in the middle of the podcast to take pictures.
A luck.
Got To fucking love him.
Fuck.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I,
I just don't know where to draw lines.
Well you do.
You're just,
you're just a nice guy and you let people grab your face.
I had to do to ask if he could pick me up once to let them know.
No,
you're not picking me up,
man.
Why did you do that Brian?
Dry Mat.
No,
I don't.
I took a car service.
I've never driven to one of your podcasts.
My life could move.
Good.
Move.
Fucking learn.
Very young.
Do you have a can opener on that thing?
This bad ass fucking knife.
Do you open up with a knife?
That's how you open up bottles.
I'm obsessed with knives.
He's days.
Oh,
that's not good.
Why are you obsessed with knives?
I love them.
I just think the coolest shit.
You love knives.
You 12 how old are,
you know,
but I feel like I'm a grown up.
Like when you started getting into pro hunting,
I was like,
man,
there's a lot of shit I can afford to do that.
I've never thought about doing that.
I would when I was a kid I was like,
I totally,
I was talking to Mike Maryfield about it when he was like,
I told him,
I thought I was like,
there's a lot of shit.
Like I want a motorcycle miles,
beers.
And he goes,
Mike Merrifield bought a motorcycle.
Dude,
I fucking love motorcycles.
You're reckless motherfucker.
Burke Christ.
No.
You'd want a motorcycle to a little bit.
Oh,
I definitely would.
Does that whole like crashing and losing your legs part?
It's not attractive to me.
Jan.
Jamie wants to get one of those little moped one,
so that's even worse.
Even worse than that.
Lose Jamie if you want to be the next Jamie.
Even worse than that are the bikes that have motors on them,
the bicycles that have motors on them,
but like,
uh,
I was like,
yeah,
there's a bunch of Shit I've wanted to do and like I can afford to buy a cool
knife every now and then.
So like when I'm on the road,
like in Brazil or somewhere,
I'll see a knife and I'll go,
you know what that remind me of my trip.
And so I buy knives.
So you're a knife collector.
Little bit.
You have.
I'm like locked up.
I'm all over the house to protect me.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Anyone ever breaks into my house?
Have a machete next to my man cave.
What the fuck bird.
You got a machete people.
I'll have a gun.
What if you machete the wrong guy?
It's like surprise.
If you're already on your way down with this.
If you're in my man cave and I'm pulling out the machete too late,
it's too late.
It's too late.
Do you have like,
like a protocol?
Like when the machete will come out.
It's a rubber with,
it's just a kid who's like got a crack problem and he's breaking in and try to
steal a stereo.
You got a machete him,
we get some machete.
Wow,
you've got a machete him,
but if he's not big,
what if you could smack him around?
It was a little tiny guy,
a little Tony Hinchcliffe looking guy too,
trying to steal your stereo.
That fucking the kids hold them down and call the cops.
Tony [inaudible].
Tony hits that.
He's that scrawny.
That scares me.
The scrappy kids probably as good stamina.
Yeah,
probably if you like start heaving Hoven you know you're in the middle of a a
prolonged battle and you started fading.
It would turn her,
turn up the heat on you and all of a sudden he was going faster than I ever saw
him go beat you over the head with one of those things that you shake up and you
see the snow in it.
This little paper weights,
that's what he's going to get.
Michelle and we have those all over my fucking house.
We have snow Globes everywhere.
Are they from all these different places?
You visit by Snow Globes for the girls.
So ridiculous Snow Globes and and blades.
So you're buying all over the world.
I'm fucking,
FBI has got a file on you about that thick traveling over the world.
They said that they were going to release some,
uh,
Greg Glenn Greenwald said they were going to release some new shit this week and
it's going to be a list of all the people that the NSA was spying on.
All the Americans.
They have a full list of everyone.
I want to be on that.
So fucking bad.
You were all on it,
dude.
We are so close.
We're so close to everything being tape recorded.
We are.
No,
no,
no.
We're being tape recorded and I've been training on podcasts one when people
like when people start recording each other,
private citizens start recording each other and not just the owner of the
clippers.
That's when it's going to go fuck.
Just so that you can get that guy fired talking shit about your boss and that
once that goes,
that's the fucking,
then everyone's gonna know.
Like I talked to a kid after one of my shows in Irvine the other day and he was
like,
and he was asking me something and I was uncomfortable with what he was asking
and he's like,
hey man,
I'm not tape recording you.
And I was like,
even in fact that he thought about it made me go,
fuck,
what's he trying to blow you?
He's like this.
He was just wanting to talk about something and I didn't want to talk about it
all weird.
And I was,
and he was like,
it was like 10 and tell me.
And I was like,
Eh,
I'm good.
He's like,
I'm not tape recording you.
But the fact that he said that,
I was like,
Oh shit,
people are fucking strange man.
They're so strange.
You'll,
you'll meet people after shows and they just start hitting you with like a
barrage of questions and you're like,
what are you doing?
Like,
are you interviewing me?
Is this for your own,
like a d did you save all these questions up and you're ready to throw them at
me?
Yeah.
People are type,
recording everything at this point.
Assume you're being tape recorded.
As soon every phone call you make,
every voice mail message,
you leave every text message you leave.
Assume all that shit is being recorded,
I assume.
Yeah.
You better live.
Don't live your life like you're being tape recorded.
Live your life.
A good fucking person.
You imagine if it turns out that the government spying a comedian,
I would fucking love that.
I just read something the other day where they admit that they are recording
people that have uh,
like a large group of people you know,
like their,
their voice is heard from a large group of people.
I'm trying to find the art right now.
Very public figures.
Figures.
Yeah.
See the thing that they,
uh,
there's,
I don't know,
it was on natural news.com so you never know.
That's,
that's site seems a little,
a little on the sketch.
Not quite sure.
But the article was saying that they had fake vaccinations in the Middle East
that gave feed people fake vaccination so they could collect DNA.
Seriously.
Yeah.
Fucking genius.
It's fucking creepy.
You're like,
you're,
you're getting away with something in another country that you could never get
away with an America like that.
In a way,
it's kind of dehumanizing because let's imagine if they were doing that in the
United States,
in the ghetto,
like let's imagine they went to Compton or watts and they were doing this and
they were getting these people that believe they're being vaccinated,
but really they would just withdrawing DNA.
Could you imagine the outrage?
It would be insane.
People would go crazy.
Why?
Well,
because we,
we're Americans and we believe that we have certain amount of rights and our
government doesn't deserve to be extracting our DNA and lying to us like,
what are you,
are you a dictator or this is,
are you the overlord or you are representative government because this doesn't
seem like a representative government.
If you're fucking giving poor people fit,
but it's okay if it's in another country.
See if it's in another country.
Somehow they could justify like,
well,
they're not even Americans.
They're humans.
They're human beings.
You're giving them fake vaccination.
So you could,
if that is true,
and again,
I don't know if it is,
but if it is,
it's a,
it's a practice that's as old as time.
People have found a way to demonize the others,
whether it's the people that they were at war with,
whether it's,
you know,
you look back at the horrific things that the Nazis did to the Jews.
Look at the horrific things that the Mongols did to all these different places
where they conquered.
Look at throughout human history,
every
time a group has been able to identify another group as the enemy,
they've been able to justify horrific things.
And that's what happened with this fucking evil kid,
this evil kid in Santa Barbara.
And that's what's happening right now with these idiots,
these male rights idiots that are battling it out with feminists online,
going back and forth.
These people that are actually saying that this guy who have girls,
fuck this guy,
he wouldn't have gone on this killing spree.
It's fucking crazy.
You can only say that if you're dealing with an us and them.
You can only say that if it's the enemy,
you know,
it's,
it's a weird thing that people do.
Man,
this enemy thing,
they'll do it with fucking the Phillies.
They'll do it with teams and Philadelphia.
Joey Diaz would telling me the story about this guy that was there and uh,
I,
it was a football game and he was,
I don't know what team this guy was wearing,
a jersey,
but he got in a fight with these guys.
They stomped his leg.
They broke his leg in a stairwell.
They threw him down and stomped his leg.
I have snapped his femur.
They stay.
Did that too in dodger stadium to the,
to God there was a fan of the writer or the beat him up days.
Days.
That scares me to not want to go to fighting it to events for sure.
But someone was telling me that just in a coma for like a week.
Right.
And you just went to a fucking game with your kid.
Yeah.
You just rooting for the wrong team or you ran into the wrong group of drunk
assholes.
And see that's where the women have a real good point because this is not
happening to men.
If you're running into women,
you're not running into drunk women coming down an alleyway and they're breaking
your leg and beating the fuck out of you.
It's trunk men.
It's men and women have to worry about it even more than men have to worry about
it.
You know,
it's,
I,
I didn't know anything about the all,
all the women or what is it?
All in the f all the women.
You're the one that,
yeah,
I just started reading about it today.
All the women.
Yeah.
And I never knew the point of view.
You know,
what happens with these things that they become so polarizing.
You think both the people who are fucking totally crazy and you lose the maybe
subtle point that should be represented in that all the women and what I,
what I realized that you kind of put it out that I think is pretty brilliant.
I never really seen it like,
Hey,
not all men rape,
but all women can get raped.
Like most of them.
Ronda Rousey's be tough as shit
kill you,
right?
When you think you raping,
you just get triangled son.
She just tells you to lick her pussy.
Right when you go in for the kill,
she slaps that triangle
and the lights go out and Georgia,
you start seeing it close in.
Oh No.
That's what it's like.
Oh,
you getting choked out.
I know.
It gets to like,
it's like an elevator door.
I'd been choked out.
Have you?
Who choked you out a fucking Henzel Gracie.
What was Gilbert?
Is that what it's called?
Kill Bert.
Bert.
Bert hurt Bert.
Know
the whatever.
Ridiculous that no wonder why your back's all fucked up,
man.
He let people throw you around and been a stunt man.
I've been a practicing stunk,
man.
That's like being a stock man.
You feel that it was it hands over the chat or voice.
Horian Horian Horian.
Oh,
the older the,
the guy who founded it at all.
He founded the UFC.
Horian was the,
he's the father of a hand air and here on,
yeah,
those,
I thought those guys too.
They fought all of them.
They had to haul beat the shit.
They just gave me a knife that I tried to strap a Brazilian.
Oh.
Which by the way gave you a knife after going to Brazil.
Holy Shit Man.
Brazilians are like the fucking sturdy Istock of human in the world.
It's a hard life over there for a lot of folks and it's also very active,
very active.
They're always on the beach like we were watching or hotel room.
These fucking surfers were incredible man.
Me and Ari were there or it came down to watch the fights down there with me
once and we were standing there on my balcony watching these kids surf.
We were also,
it was like a,
you know,
your time is all fucked up.
It's like several hours in the future.
Like,
what is it like three or four hours ahead of,
I think it's the head of New York.
Yeah.
I don't remember like six hours,
whatever it was.
I was all whacked out,
so it was like five o'clock in the morning.
We were still up and the sun was coming up like five,
six,
whatever it was,
and all of a sudden these people started showing up at the beach,
like kids and adults and flip flops and everybody was hanging out and like,
wow,
these people are active bikes start running by six Sam joggers and shit.
I was like,
these are like really active people.
Then all of sudden that soccer game broke out,
so it was like seven o'clock in the morning with drinking coffee and watching
people play soccer on the beach like this is,
this is interesting.
I'm like,
there's so much more active than the average Americans.
Yeah.
You know,
if people here get fucking super sedentary,
man,
I am
super common.
It's more common than not.
Right.
I think my whole thing now is like I have my weight set up in my backyard,
so I go,
if I'm fucking,
if I,
if I get like a little weird funk,
I go fuck it.
Lift weights.
Because I know for a fact that like lifting weights to the point where your of
your tits are all fire,
that releases some serotonin in your body.
You should be a doctor and that should be a meme lifting weights until your tits
were,
I know that releases some Sarah Tillery and your body,
Bert Kreischer and you holding your tits.
Yeah,
that'd be a great meme.
Not meme,
um,
uh,
gifts you texted,
made a Gif,
Gif,
gif files.
Yeah.
That's a great way to fucking cover sports on the Internet.
Like you posted something about the fight that's Oh yeah.
You know what it was.
It wasn't that I posted something.
I'll tell you exactly what it was.
There was a thing on fight land where someone broke down a Hanan Barao,
a guy named Jack Slack.
It's how Tj Dillashaw killed the king and it's on fight land.
It's one of the,
um,
the vice channels.
And I'm vice,
this guy did a great job of breaking down like the technical aspects of a Hanan
Barao style and how,
what Tj Dillashaw was able
to exploit it.
And in doing so,
he used these animated gifs as,
um,
as,
uh,
examples of different specific moments in the fight where things changed and
what Tj did well and what Hanan Barao did wrong.
He's really good at breaking things down.
That's,
but that's also,
they're in cahoots with the UFC.
That's why they're allowed to use those animated gif files.
But it's a great way to cover.
That's great.
Fantastic.
I'm,
and I'm glad that Ken,
but other people in other sites like if you try to,
you know,
put up animated Gif files,
they'll get pissed at you.
Yeah.
They don't want it.
Animated Gif files.
Did you follow this?
A Floyd Mayweather.
I fight.
I saw some shit on online,
like some of the,
you know,
Flint mayor was saying,
you gotta you gotta Control Your Bitch Bitch.
Um,
you know,
if you want to get in a fight with Floyd Mayweather and you're a rapper,
good.
Good luck with all that.
Like,
what's all this chair throwing with Saul?
Stop the nonsense and realize that you're not going to get into a fucking fight
cause one of the greatest boxers that's ever walked the face of the the world.
Can we,
can we just agree on that?
Yeah.
You're just bullshitting.
Okay.
Because if there's no one here,
but you and him and you are both in a room with no objects,
just your body's let's start over.
They're both fucking millionaires in their water burger.
Like I don't get,
get hungry and people get hungry.
You're so high profile and your Floyd Mayweather.
What do you likes?
Burgers.
Burgers all the time.
That's like part of his thing.
Like he,
he would always be like driving around in his Bentley and he beat,
you know,
like a Jack in the box.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Tia,
I can take on Floyd Mayweather.
Just sign.
Did he really say that?
Yeah,
he,
he's posted a video that,
wait a minute,
they sent us a video of him like working out or something.
Like why is he ended his,
his,
it's about his um,
dump place.
Supposed to have black eyes silly.
They said he had black eyes and he's saying he didn't.
All that happened is he hurt his hand and he had his hand wrapped,
I think.
But I think the threat is the Gis posse's going to shoot Floyd Mayweather.
Oh,
not that they're going to fist fight.
Cause he said,
he said Floyd Mayweather said to him in this interaction was,
I think maybe you forgot what I did for a living,
right.
I fight and t I said I fight,
but in the streets I fight for real.
And so I think that was a,
uh,
a veiled threat of a,
yeah,
I fight too,
but we do it and we'd kill you.
Or we really analyzing the Tei Floyd Mayweather discussion and who got the most
out of their verbal exchange.
Floyd made a very good point.
That t,
I forgot what he does for a living,
but what Floyd forgot his TEI keeps it real fucking in the trap.
He's from the streets and he's still connected to those streets.
I'm most impressed with tiny,
who's tying his flow?
Tiny.
Is it the guy's wife?
She's not even really that hot,
but they're fucking fighting over to fucking millionaires.
Why are you impressed?
They're idiots.
This is the whole thing for target.
The whole thing is so stupid,
whatever.
That's not what it is.
It's,
it's an ego thing.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
The whole thing is ridiculous.
How dare you talk about it for so long.
I'm disgusted.
I'm disgusted by the whole scenario.
I'm done.
Thank you.
So who's the cook brothers?
What are,
what is the Koch brothers brothers like we talked about him before by super rich
do is that you don't want to talk about in a podcast or they will come fuck you.
How about that?
Next?
They,
uh,
they just fuck the Columbus zoo up.
And how did they fuck up the Columbus zoo?
Stephen Colbert did a really quick blurb about it and he explains it perfectly,
but pretty much what they did is they,
they had this big valid on the,
uh,
on level the latest vote that said,
hey,
we need to make money or are zoos is going to close down.
So we're going to raise property tax by just a teeny teeny bit.
And the Koch brothers were like,
yeah,
you're going to go up like 105% in your,
your property taxes.
When in reality it was only going to be 20 bucks.
But to all the voters voted against it and now the zoos like we're fucked.
We don't know what to do.
I mean like lied about how much the property.
Yeah.
And this is like one of the number one,
number two zoos in the nation and,
and now they're fun.
This is one of Jack Hanna's from zoos are weird man.
Cause I agree with them with certain animals.
But those most animals in the zoo,
I think zoos,
I think the only way you should really be able to have a zoo and be able to
pretend that it's humane is do it the way they do in Africa.
But don't have people hunt in there.
You know in Africa.
The reason why they have so many God damn animals now,
cause they have these huge preserves,
thousands and thousands of acres and they have these animals run free.
But they do it so they could profit off it.
They bring in hunters and the hunters hump these wild animals.
So they think they're on a wild animal hunting.
They technically or on a wild animal hub.
But really these,
it's a cage ton.
These animals,
I mean they are hunting lions but those lines aren't going anywhere.
You know,
it's like it's a very sketchy area when it comes to um,
people that believe in fair chase hunting.
Like the Africa thing is a fucker because the other problem is they do preserve
those populations this way.
Cause other than that,
no one else is trying to keep the eland alive.
No one,
you know,
no one is working hard to make sure that all these different versions of
antelope or healthy populations if it wasn't for these hunters.
But it gets,
it gets real weird when you start thinking about like zoos because we'll,
okay,
what's a zoo?
We only have like a couple of them.
You have like a two giraffes are three giraffes.
You have like a couple and everybody's separated from everybody and you're all
in this weird non-natural environment where nobody can move around.
I'm not opposed to like a giant animal park where you could kind of drive
through,
but I think you've got to let nature take its course in that motherfucker.
You got to have monkeys swinging through the trees above Jaguars.
You gotta have,
you gotta have giraffes that are running away from lions.
You got to have the whole thing.
Cause if you don't have the whole thing,
what are you doing?
You're taking these animals and you're deciding that their reality,
their nature itself is not humane.
Like it's not right.
It's not right to seem very dated.
Now that you say that,
it seems like a throwback to the thirties
it's from when people didn't have DVDs,
they didn't have the animal planet.
They have any of these things where they can go and watch a show on a species
and watch a fascinating documentary.
You only way to see it would be to go see it in live.
But you go to the zoo.
Oh Daddy,
look at the elephant.
You would never see a lion if you didn't see it in a zoo in the fucking,
in the 30s absolutely.
I'm pretty,
I think though a lot of people are getting like see roads shit mixed up with
like zoos though because I think that's why everyone didn't know that.
See Road kidnapped these,
they thought that,
oh these were taken here because they were injured more.
The zoo,
like I,
I just moved to San Diego Zoo zoo,
one of the best zoos in the nation,
San Diego and uh,
they have this whole thing.
We did the tour this time and they had this whole thing that you can tell,
it's almost them getting ready for the,
their version of black fish that's coming up because they were already talking
like,
look,
we hate animals in cages.
Awesome.
But we are nonprofit.
We,
these animals right here,
there was only two left in the road.
We thought this animal was extinct in 1960 was the last time we saw this,
this one kind of pig or whatever it was.
And he's like,
he's like,
now there's 20 of them because we take them here.
We breed them and then we put them back into the wild.
Now I don't think they put them in Africa.
They're probably put it in some,
you know,
baby version of it.
Do put it in Africa.
They put them in these wildlife sanctuaries,
this gigantic places where they let people hunt them.
They just don't let them hunt that pig.
That's what they do.
But,
but it was,
it was very eye opening for this.
This,
when I went to this one,
because they were showing us all the work they've done.
Like,
like there was like only two of these birds.
Now there's a 200 and every animal on there says they're endangered.
Well what their,
their level of endangerment.
Now there's like monkeys,
like some monkeys.
There's a billion of these monkeys so they don't give a shit,
you know?
But most of those animals in there are only in there for a reason because
they're injured or whatever.
And then they're getting put it back in the wild.
And that's why we're like these Cook Koch brother things.
You know,
where they're completely lying there.
All these animals are screwed.
These animals,
like this is one of the best zoos in the nation that they've taken care of.
So many,
you know,
the white lion or a,
I think it was came,
you know,
it's endanger white line that they had there.
Yeah.
Back in the day and check this one clip out.
This is how fucked up this thing is with the Columbus Zoo for prosperity.
That's hilarious.
That's so funny.
And it's so true.
Yeah.
So why do they want that property?
What do they want to do with it?
I,
you know,
I don't know anything about that.
I just found out about this the other day.
I was,
cause I was talking about how the zoo was so,
such a great thing growing up,
you're going to lose it.
Totally.
I,
I don't know that they have until November,
but they're also fucked till November.
And I dunno man.
Growing up I went to summer camp at the zoo and Jack Hanna was our camp leader
and we would like spend the night at the zoo and it was just the best childhood
memory ever learning about animals being at the zoo,
you know.
And it's,
it really sucks that zoos are getting kind of attached to this whole black fish
seaworld bullshit cause it's really once making profit and one's trying to make
profit office stolen the animals from the water and one's just trying to help
animals.
We are zoos.
Are Zoos more a nonprofit organizations?
Most of them are,
yeah.
Well the,
the,
the itch that people that have an issue with zoos have an issue with the
conditions.
They have an issue.
Like there was a zoo that I was driving limos once and I was coming home from a
Gig that I had a,
I had to drop somebody off in New Hampshire and I was driving down and there was
a zoo and just on a Lark I just said,
well let me see what the zoo looks like.
And I,
I went to this little tiny zoo and there was this,
there was a lion and a bear and the lion,
it was the saddest fucking thing ever.
This line was just pacing back and forth.
His tiny little enclosure and there was nowhere to go.
It was just pacing back and forth.
It was all concrete and it's like little pond forum and I was like,
this is the saddest shit I've ever seen.
This thing is just pace.
It can't go anywhere and he can't,
it does.
It doesn't get to kill anything.
It doesn't get to be a lion doesn't get to be aligned,
just pacing back and forth,
back and forth.
And um,
I just remember thinking like,
how is that better than it not being alive?
Like that's not,
but what?
Just so we could look at it.
So it's,
it's a,
it's better than not be know that thinks she'd be dead.
It's better off being dead than living like that.
That's crazy.
Or let the mother fucker go bring it back to Africa.
Put It,
if you really give a shit about lions,
set up cameras set up,
can't we make people go there on Safari?
Make people drive around,
see the actual real thing,
you know,
maybe it'll really get an appreciation for what it's like to live in Africa.
If you could actually see them in a wild conditions.
You see like,
but San Diego is huge.
The thing about that animal park that's really dope is that they have big
enclosures like the area where the giraffes are.
Holy Shit,
it's fucked.
Is this the safari place?
Hey,
drive around the zoo.
Yeah.
But they also have the safari thing.
And another cool thing is they also do a lot of alternative methods to make the
animals not go crazy.
Like they hide the food.
They will,
they'll take the animals out,
they'll go round Hyde neat and like trees and bushes and putting it inside of
things.
And then that the animals just like their natural habitat,
look on hunt for food.
So there's a lot of things that they do.
Like the elephants have these new things that they created,
uh,
called uh,
the hey pen Jada's and it's these huge Penn Jada's with hey inside of them.
So the elephant has to work out and try to beat these things open to the zoo.
And then there's a wild animal park.
We're just two different things.
That's what it is.
I've only been to the wild animal park zoo.
The zoo is humongous if you think that wild animal park zoo,
it's crazy.
Bit of both.
Real Bill.
Yeah,
and all I can think is the bad.
The alternative ways to keep them unoccupied that you would come up with if you
work there,
you're like,
hey guys,
I felt one of our trainer outfits with meat.
We're going to give it to lions.
See if he can,
they definitely should let animals go and let the animals kill him.
I mean,
it's so ridiculous that they have to butcher the animal.
It's like,
come on,
what are you doing?
Like letter an ally and be alliance.
That's a,
that's the saddest is it's like,
it's just like the same as what we were talking about with kids in school.
Kids got a little bit of a fucking quirk and all of a sudden they're like,
no,
he's not fitting in the form.
Well,
how about this?
What if they gave me a pill?
What if they gave you a pill that made uh,
the,
the common your balls dry up,
but it kept you horny.
You know that that wouldn't be acceptable.
It's like,
well look,
we've checked his balls is very little common area,
but he's like,
I'm on book.
Oh all done.
But the balls don't know.
Well that's what it's like to be aligned and get fed meat.
They're just sliding meet under the door.
So every day you're eating and be like,
I didn't kill Shit today.
And so you get this thing where everything that moves past you,
you look at,
you roll a ball of yarn past a lion,
they jump on it just like a cat does.
It's like they have that instinct.
Cats have an instinct to chase moving thing.
So it alliance,
it's part of why they're Elian.
It's like their whole reward system.
Their whole genetic reward system is geared up to fuck and to chase things and
the cash dominate the whole deal.
The all of it is supposed to be a part and the mail's supposed to protect the,
the pack.
What did they pride rather?
The female's supposed to hunt it.
They have instincts to do these things and all those instincts you just
completely shut off.
And then they're in this enclosure with nothing else but them.
And every now and then some food comes in.
They're like,
okay,
well here's our food.
What kind of fucking life is this?
Yeah,
it's a life completely outside of the adventure of being alive in the adventure
of being aligned is the adventure of being a predator.
That's the whole thing about being aligned,
that their whole existence is based on chasing down the week.
There's like the cleaning system and like they're,
they're like making sure that the genetics of the wild stay strong.
They liked the genetics,
integrity,
experts.
Anybody that's weak,
anybody's limping,
anybody that's slept in and anybody that gets cocky and goes near the water hall
without paying attention to the grass,
moving your fucks.
Vale.
And that's how nature has it set up to make sure there's not too many fucking
antelopes.
They have a whole system,
but we come along and go,
fuck your system.
We have a system to,
it's called [inaudible] and this is called a fence and this is a tray.
And on its meat he'd go eat it.
We're gonna stare at you.
You got to stare at me.
Like staring at a lion is unheard of.
You imagine being a fucking lion and there's glass and all these little pink
monkeys have the audacity to look you in the fucking eye and you're like
all day everybody avoid your eye contact.
You're welcome to walk around like a fucking hall monitor.
Everyone sees you and like get the fuck away.
And then Dan there you believe what that must be like for this poor fucking
lines.
Oh,
for a lion,
if a lion is walking through the grass and something locks eyes with it to like
fuck.
That's the immediate reaction.
You see those eyes,
those fucking weird orangy amber eyes attach to this giant fucking skull of
death.
He just run immediately run,
get with the pack,
hope they get the slow one behind you.
Fucking trip your friend run.
It's a lion.
But meanwhile at the zoo we're like,
well look,
he's right there,
mom hook.
He's right there.
Knock,
knock,
knock.
Yeah.
What they should do is take those old zoos that are kind of like haggard and
they should fill it with like celebrities,
like celebrities.
Like,
no,
I'm not saying Tom Sizemore is a mess,
but give them booze and alcohol and put them in a cage and let you stare at him
and him just say whatever the fuck he wants because he's getting paid $1 million
for one year to be in a cage.
That's not enough money.
What is the New York you worked for the moon at the New York at the New York
City.
You did that move knows and Massachusetts.
We actually did it at a zoo that is,
um,
is not,
it's not operational right now.
It's kind of going under.
That's kind of so was celebrities fill up with fucking all sweetie.
That,
that idea sucks.
What's better than my other idea,
which was we just put cages in the wild and you can go in the wild and have
those animals around you.
Yeah.
That's a better idea.
Like I cause that when I go,
I went swimming with sharks with my daughter's a couple of weeks,
few weeks ago in why?
How was that?
I love it.
Fucking love it.
So what do you do?
You go actually in scuba gear or you go under the sharks,
what do you do again?
They,
you take,
they take out like three miles.
It's all,
it's all like a eco ecofriendly like they don't feed the sharks,
but the sharks just come out because that's where they think they're fishermen
dropping bait.
And so they go out and you get,
you get in the cage,
they pull the boat away and you're just sitting in a cage.
Just the boats like 30 yards away from you,
40 yards away from you and the sharks.
There's least 20 fucking sharks.
Dirty sharks.
I've done this one place like five times.
What part of Hawaii is this?
A wahoo.
Wahoo.
Fucking amazing.
So what is it like for your kids?
Uh,
they were scared at first,
but what happened was I just told the guys who ran the boat,
who I knew,
because I'd done it for TV.
I told him,
I said,
you just be in charge.
Don't let anyone say no,
just be in charge.
This is how we do it guys.
Everyone get your masks on and grab your mask.
Everyone get your mask.
Ali got your mask.
And so there's no point where they can get out of it by talking to me.
Cause I knew they wanted to do it by knew that we're going to be scared.
And I would let,
I would never let them do something they weren't,
didn't feel safe doing.
But the guys did it.
And the girls were just in Rome.
They were like,
okay.
He's like,
all right,
this foot right here,
this foot right here.
Here we go.
And then we're going to back into the cage.
There you go.
I'll,
you're in first Georgia.
I'm already in the cage and I get them and they're like holding on and you can
see they're scared.
And I got to go pro going on.
I filmed all of it and I was a seven to nine.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
That's really cool.
And they fucking loved it.
The first look you can see she's scared out of,
puts her face in the water and then pops up.
And I just caught it on the Gopro and she's so excited.
She throws her face right back in the water to look again.
And they were,
uh,
they were boggling.
They had so much fucking fun.
Well,
if you feel safe and you could really see sharks out in the wild,
it's gotta be pretty wild.
Be a kid to see something like that and you're in the cage for the first time in
their lives.
They're the one in the cage and the cage is a pretty safe,
right?
I mean,
it just really say a giant ass fucking great white to fuck that cage up.
Or is that just in the movies?
You know,
so crazy.
We get out of the cage and a,
and a whale to whales come by.
Oh Shit.
Big Ass fucking wheels.
Like maybe 20 feet off the boat.
I got this on video too.
Wow.
20 feet off the boat,
swim around the back and dive right by the cage.
And I threw my Gopro in.
One of the guys grabbed it.
She got the whales going down and it was surreal.
But what's crazy as you think,
if those whales decided they could just fucking jump up and land on the boat,
the cage,
and we're all dead as fuck.
Does that ever happen?
Yeah.
It happened with the sailboat in Australia.
A whale just jumped up and landed on the sailboat.
Yeah.
What are you showing Brian?
Burt's.
I wouldn't trip like we do it.
That's the cage.
Yeah.
Same foods that we do want to triple it.
We've done it twice and I love it so much because it's one of those moments
where you really have this like kind of surreal life experience.
What it's like going to church and getting it.
Wow.
I want to go.
It's a lot of fucking fun.
Scuba diving.
It seems like it'd be crazy to just,
and you've done that right?
Yeah.
I'm going to scuba [inaudible] for trip.
But I'm not certified.
I've done it.
I do you like do a day certification.
It's like entering into just the very front patio of another world.
You know?
It's like you just open the front door.
He's Stan,
you look around,
you kind of go in a couple of steps,
but it's a whole other world out there.
There's a lot of things that I've done on the show that,
um,
that are,
are mine,
like riding motorcycles.
I would've never done that if it wasn't for that show,
but now dude,
it is that you have often rushing in the world.
You not worried about crashing?
Of course I am,
but that's what makes it maybe you could get like a,
a big Harley type bike drive slow,
don't get crazy and only drive in populated areas.
That's what they say.
Where else?
A lot of traffic.
They say young leaving the comedy store last night and one of those off like
this crazy four by four motorcycle.
Fake motorcycles.
TV like like Dmx?
Yeah,
like what's that one?
What was he driving when those ones,
it's almost looks like it has training wheels but it's a motorcycle.
It's like a trike and trike.
Yeah,
I knew what I was going to tell you.
What's he doing on that?
I don't know.
It was weird seeing him on that.
We grown up in Florida.
We played bows and arrows all the time like it was meant to tell you this and so
we're in Hawaii.
We went on a boar hunt where in Hawaii where we chase it with the dogs and then
stab it in the launch for trip flip.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's a crazy fucking trip.
Oh,
who's was,
is that someone's idea?
That guy's idea?
No,
it was our idea.
Oh,
it was your idea for them.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
you got to go murder an animal that's murdering you.
Gotta you gotta you gotta run it by them and you know,
be like,
you cool with this.
I'm never going to put someone in a situation and if they weren't cool that we
just wouldn't have done it.
Right.
But it's,
look,
it's,
I believe this,
if you're going to enjoy bacon,
you better be cool with the harvest.
Yes.
I believe that.
And so,
um,
so we get it like a thing full of pimples and we go catch a pig,
hold it down.
My guy grabs a knife,
stabs in the heart,
and then when they,
then they tie it up,
they tie the feet and legs together,
like the wrists and the ankles together.
And I wear it like a backpack carrying it out of the woods.
Fucking heavy ass pitch.
But the best part is that I know and I know I can fuck around with a bone arrow
pretty easily and be okay.
So we're with all these real fucking Hawaiian hunters and they got everything
they got and they've got in their backyard,
this huge house.
They've got the Hay bales with the target.
And I said,
I bet anyone in the crew right now,
I can get close to a bullseye.
I can hit the target from like hugging,
not 100 yards,
but like 50 yards under the tent.
I said,
I can do it from under the tent.
There's a big fucking fennel,
this,
there's a tent and you're going to shoot from under the tent out through the
tent into the fucking bullseye.
And they're like,
just by shooting.
Wait a minute,
what kind of a boat?
You're talking about a compound bow and it's going to go 50 yards.
It's gonna go,
I'm gonna.
I'm guessing you get assigned a ballpark right now.
I don't remember.
Are you looking through a site?
They have it.
Well there is a site on the,
there was a site on this on a string and then another site,
the aligning the site up with,
uh,
it was,
it was the,
uh,
it was,
there was a site,
I don't know what site it was,
but in my head I'm like,
I can confidently do it without the site.
Like,
cause I'm getting hit the bullseye from fifth night,
not the bullseye by sending could hit the target.
It's,
but,
and I really hard to do really hard to do it,
but I know I can do it.
So I'm like,
I go who's in?
And I was,
and everyone's like,
bullshit,
bullshit.
I get one of the fucking tent,
I pull back,
I hold it.
And as soon as I pull the back,
once you pull compound bow back,
it's easy to hold.
And so I hold it and I start lining up the site seeing lucky as fuck.
I hit the target and I like,
part of me was like,
I don't know if I can do this,
but everyone on the crew was like,
shut the fuck up.
So then everyone on the crew tried to do it.
They couldn't even pull the compound bow back like they were.
They were like,
there's a picture I posted on Instagram a while and my buddy Eric trying to pull
the bow back and he couldn't even get it all the way back.
How many pounds of pole was it?
I Dunno.
Just one of the guys is pretty,
it was a pretty heavy bowl.
It's very difficult to hit a target that's 50 yards,
50 yards,
maybe longer than I may be exaggerating for,
but I don't know.
This is very difficult to know where the pin's going.
Like if you would have to,
if you have a pin on a boat,
there's two different types of pens.
Does a single pin and a single pin.
You rotate forward and backward with this site.
So the site has like a yardage on it.
So like you have it set at 20 yards,
20 yards is like,
we're like maybe a shortish shot would be like,
say if you're going to Trieste.
It was longer than it was longer than 20 yards.
Okay.
So then if it's longer,
what you do is you put a,
uh,
like a laser sight on it.
You Lock on how far it is,
the exact distance.
He was drunk.
I was drunk.
Then you dial it back.
But my point is that an Arrow,
when you shoot an now,
if like 50 yards,
it's going to drop considerably.
Especially depending on how strong the bow is,
how heavy the Arrow is.
This is very hard.
The may not have been 50 yards,
but it was definitely further for a shit.
Okay.
You feel like you could do it again?
Yeah.
Wow.
Dude,
you gotta come over my house.
Was She?
Dude,
it's so funny that you're gonna make a video of those.
We,
I told you we,
when we were kids,
we used to do them with our feet.
Like that was our big things because we went to a camp was all bone arrowheads,
recurve bow.
Is that what it was?
I have regular bow and arrow.
We did.
We it compound though,
right?
There wasn't a compound bow.
We did.
We went deer.
We went hunting in Italy with bows.
But the ones that you got to hold the arrows,
you got to hold the boat sideways,
sideways.
It was still like some bows.
You can't just like,
uh,
dammit man,
I wish I was smarter and I paid attention more.
Oh,
I know what you're saying.
Because they don't have arrest,
they don't have a rest.
So you've got to hold it sideways and to shoot the bow that way.
The way the Mongols used to do it right.
And I'd never shot with one of those boats,
but I was cocky vent too.
And I was like,
oh I got this.
It's that grew up with bows and arrows and I fucking pulled it back and I
fucking could not hit this goddamn deer.
I fuck.
I mean I tried like it's not an easy thing to do man.
It's really regular bow,
regular bows or hardy shit.
Compound bows are a little more user friendly and my opinions Wazier yeah,
it's way easier.
That's why they say that if you really want to learn about an error,
you should learn on a traditional,
like a recurve.
Yeah.
It's cause becomes like,
you know,
like you,
if you were shooting a three pointer,
you know,
you kinda gotta you,
you throw it a few times and you kind of get a judge of how hard you have to
throw it and then eventually you get it,
you figure it out.
Well that's the whole idea behind a recurve is that you've got to figure out how
far that Arrow is going to go,
what's going to be the trajectory.
And if you shoot a hundred hours a day over the course of years,
you develop a real feel for it.
And some guys,
like I bought my bow at this place in Los Alamitos and the guy who,
uh,
owns,
it's been shooting bows and arrows since he was like a kid and he's in his
probably in his sixties and he just picked up this bow,
slapped an arrow on it.
When,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm telling you like within like five or six seconds from picking the bow up,
putting the Arrow on shit he had let go and nail the target,
hit a bullseye at 20 yards.
I mean it was,
it was like this click,
click.
I mean it took no time at all.
He's just so he's like when you've shot as many hours as I have,
you just kind of know where the Arrow is going to go.
Just based on the numbers,
like the input,
like if you throw a hundred free throws,
he kind of get an idea of how hard you have to throw that free throw.
You'd shoot a hundred arrows,
you go,
oh that's over there and you,
your,
your brain almost has like a calculator as far as like distant,
like,
like are you going to throw a rock?
You kind of know how far,
you know,
if I give you a rock and the rock is like the size of a golf ball,
you're like,
think I could throw it over there.
It kind of have a good idea where this rocks going.
It's muscle memory too.
Definitely.
It's input.
It's like you get enough input,
you shoot all these arrows like that one went there,
that one there.
Okay,
I see where it's going on.
And then you start calculating up in your brain and then your mind knows exactly
how high you should raise that Arrow,
you know,
so that it compensates for the distance that has to travel and the drop that
it's going to have over the course of time.
Yeah.
But with a compound bow,
you don't do that as much you do with a site.
I want to say there was a green laser on it,
but I can't remember.
Yeah,
they have this thing Trijicon has one,
it looks like a green laser,
but it's really like a triangle and you rotate it forward and backward depending
on how the distances,
these guys would totally take you if you want to go boar hunting in Hawaiian
next time we was on [inaudible].
But uh,
if I go to Hawaii,
it's with my family and I'm not coming home bloody.
There's certain things that I separate all my manly type behaviors really
separated from my little girls.
Yeah.
I don't think I want them to see me fucking stab a bore with a knife.
What dogs are holding it down?
What you doing?
I bet if they saw a real wild pig though,
they'd probably be completely freaked out because like,
fuck yeah.
Pigs to them are these cute things.
They did see,
we took them to,
um,
there's a,
a farm up in,
um,
southern California,
forget the name of the farm,
but you go there,
it's like you could pick your own vegetables and you can,
um,
you can,
uh,
they wave them for you.
Like you pick radishes and whatever and it's fun,
you know,
the kids get to do that and,
but they also have this fucking pig that's as big as this table dude.
I mean,
is the biggest pig you've ever seen in your life.
It's just gigantic,
this huge thing.
And they tweak out on that thing.
They're like,
what the fuck is like?
They think of a pig as being like a cute little pay.
Like they have stuffed piggies,
you know,
uh,
one of my daughters is a piggy backpack that she wears.
Sometimes it's a little pink piggy and then they're seen as fucking wallowing,
mud covered BMS,
enormous pig.
It's so fucking big.
And they're like,
what is that?
I'm like,
that's a pig.
Like,
no,
it's not.
That's on a pig.
Yeah,
that's a pig.
It's not pink.
Pigs aren't pink.
They're not all pink.
Like what?
And he can see their little faces.
They little computer spinning like that's a fucking pig.
I mean things just this big around fat fucked up.
Oh,
covenant Mage.
Just discuss.
It is a disgusting animal.
But if you see a wild one,
they're even more gangster.
Yeah,
but they don't taste good.
Wild woman.
Wild pigs.
You're out of your mind.
What they told us.
Don't tell,
don't listen to anybody.
They're delicious.
I shot a wild pig and made ham and it's the best ham I've ever had in my life.
Serious.
Smoked it over to like at least 10 hours.
I don't know how many hours it took.
Takes a lot time.
Isn't there a truth to the fact of what the pig eats?
You are then eating.
So if it's living off like fucking shitty vegetation,
it's going to take shitty because they were telling us the pig.
Normally when they,
they'll catch the pig and then they'll put it and keep it if feed it good too.
That's not a pig and the pig family.
Well,
yeah,
you can do that.
I mean,
you definitely could do that.
And some guys do that too to get the pig fatter.
Like some of the wild pigs aren't as fat.
The wild pig that I shot though is that to hone ranch,
which is like rich and acorns and all these different things that the pigs can
eat.
It was fat.
It was delicious.
It was so good,
man.
I smoked it,
um,
uh,
in one of those smokers and I brined it for like six days before I smoked it.
Brian.
Yeah.
That was some of the best meeting I've ever had in my really delicious,
if I had to choose one meat that I've ever had ever,
that would have been the one that chose as the best meeting I've ever been told
us.
They told us someone we killed,
they're like,
it's not going to taste that great,
but they're idiots.
They're taking it home and eating it.
They don't know what they're doing either.
Yeah,
that's probably that I found out that that was true about,
um,
Marlin,
like you catch a Marlin,
they tell you,
oh you can't even eat these,
you know,
meanwhile,
yeah,
you can eat a Marlin that it's like swordfish and to chop it up in steaks.
But when you,
it's kind of a racket when you,
uh,
pay for someone to take your fishing or pay for someone to take your hunting.
Sometimes they want that meat and they're like,
you don't even want this meat,
dude.
This is a bad meat.
Really.
Like,
oh,
it's okay.
It's bad.
Mean.
Wild pig is some of the most delicious meat you will ever eat in your life.
Without a doubt.
I can say that with a hundred percent confidence cause I haven't just eaten this
pig.
I've eaten other people's pigs.
They're shot and it's fucking fantastic.
Do you think maybe that's just Hawaiian then?
No.
No tire note.
These are telling you they're bullshitting you.
Hawaiians are famous for Lou owls.
What did they cook?
Are there Louis pigs?
Why do they cook pigs?
Because that's what they hunt.
They have wild pigs all over Hawaii.
It's one of the few animals that they brought over with them.
When people call an Hawaii like it's one of the few animals that they left loose
and they became feral.
They have deer,
they have different axis deer and some of the islands they have some mountain
goats and some of the places,
but maybe,
or maybe I missed who the fuck dude,
they fucked you and they stole your pig.
We,
we weren't going to take it home.
Well,
they probably didn't want you to eat any of it.
They didn't want you to bring it back to the restaurant.
They could probably sell it.
I don't know though.
They were good guys.
I don't think they're are good guys.
You're on TV,
whatever.
Whatever.
I love.
Give me a hug.
Give me a hug and give me that fucking pig.
He said they stole your pig,
Bro.
It's no big deal.
They're delicious,
man.
Don't let anybody tell you different.
There's a lot of animals that people will tell you that they're not good to eat.
Like another one that keeps coming up as black bear and like someone got mad at
my friend Cameron Hanes.
I posted this video of him shooting a black bear with a bow and arrow.
People like,
that's fucking horrible.
That's disgusting.
They don't even eat those.
They taste like shit.
There's all these people saying they taste terrible.
I've had black bear tastes delicious.
It tastes weird.
It definitely is different.
Like you kind of know you're eating a bear because he's like a bear.
It's a different taste,
but it's good.
It's like if you ever had elk,
yeah,
delicious,
but you'll be really fucking good.
No,
you're eating when you're eating out you're like,
Ooh,
this is different.
It's kind of crazy.
It's like that wild pig that didn't taste like anything else right now that just
tastes,
it tastes like ham.
You've tasted Sigar,
but word of for core lately stopped doing that.
He,
he's like Kodiak,
Kodiak.
It's a dip that's got a bear on the copper
is a different kind of berries reluctant.
You saw when,
when I was getting my nose fixed,
he was like find reluctant bear being a Bareback,
that jogging and shit.
Oh,
just taking them on the road.
It probably wasn't doing so well.
It isn't as much money for food,
you know,
now I can eat whatever the fuck he wants.
You ever see the pictures of him when he was at in high school?
No.
He looks like a male model.
A swear to God.
I swear to God he,
he sent some picture.
I don't know what it was,
but it was,
he looked like a male model.
I was like,
he's a funny dude.
He's so fucking funny.
Finally do it.
I love hanging out with that guy too.
We just did the comedy Magic Club together a couple of weeks ago.
Last week or so.
Funny Dude,
man Thomson [inaudible].
He was the only guy out of all the people that I went on that maxim comedy tour
with,
um,
that I,
uh,
I really stayed friends with.
Um,
like out of the guys that opened,
I'm still friends with Charlie Murphy and half Ron.
But there was like,
we had 22 different openers,
but one of them stood out.
It was the girl.
Do you remember any of the other ones?
Yeah.
Josh McDermitt.
No,
no,
no.
Josh McDermitt opened up for us in Phoenix when he did a competition and that
was a funny story.
It was one of the Joey Diaz missing in action videos.
Joey Diaz and fucking vanish like a fucking pow and numb and you couldn't get
any words were fuck he was,
I started bringing two guys in the road from me for that very reason.
And that was one of those times where Joey advantaged,
Joey vanished.
And we couldn't get ahold of them.
So who was it was Mcdermott.
And who else was at Dunkin or Ari?
Ari.
Shit.
It might've been mad at Kirsch.
It was a long ass time ago.
It might've been.
Who knows who it was,
but whoever it was,
we had to get someone.
And we were there the night before because I had to do radio and we've watched
this local contest and Josh McDermitt went up and he was living in Phoenix at
the time.
He's fucking hilarious.
And so now he's on the walking dead.
It's crazy.
Oh,
are you shitting me?
He's one of the,
he's a super smart scientist dude in the walking dead.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah,
that dude,
he uh,
he did the podcast before he did the podcast a long time ago.
Ice House chronical.
Yeah.
What does this dude,
five o four what's that?
What's episodes?
That's five oh four.
This is five oh six.
Jesus Christ.
Josh McDermitt is a good dude.
He got to get them on the podcast posts that show and have him come and talk
about it.
I've been trying,
he's going to,
as soon as he get,
how many they,
oh yeah,
they fill in like crazy.
I mean the shows down,
so that means they're filming the next season.
Fuck.
Doing one of those shows,
man.
That's the rest of your life.
When you do a show like that,
like those,
those shows,
they take 16 hours a day to film.
If you hear her,
that claim,
that's the Jack Daniels Char Slo,
I'm celebrating goes,
yeah,
you are celebrating,
celebrating,
fine.
I'm an accomplished author.
I have a pug liver,
your liver and the liver is good.
It's on the other side of my body.
It hadn't been hurting at all.
Gimme a Swig of that,
Mr crusher is whiskey or Maine liquor.
Is that your big go through like a tequila phase or do you go through phases?
Like I may only do vodka.
Like what happened in the machine back guy by the way?
Well,
it's fucking dead.
That was the biggest fucking mistake of my life.
What happened?
Oh,
it's just a nightmare,
man.
And what'll happen is
someone will hear this and I appreciate everyone who helped out thank you every
month.
I know you all are big fans of Joe's podcast.
Um,
uh,
it just,
it,
it's a racket.
It's,
you can understand why it's a family run businesses that you can't get in.
It's like a country club.
And so it's like,
and no one wanted to deliver business and it just is really expensive.
And because puff daddy get in there,
honestly,
you could probably do it.
You could probably do it,
but yeah,
yeah.
But to be me and do it is impossible.
Like one of the first people I told you about was really great.
I was a great fucking investment I thought and what it was his travel size vodka
pouches.
Remember I told you about that one really easy stamp,
the face on the cover and you do these travel pouches,
they're great for summer.
You put them in your drinks and,
and it's really cheap.
The problem is they were like,
okay,
well you went $250,000 and your shipping will be ready to be picked up on
Thursday.
And I was like,
okay,
understand the money.
But even when my shipment and they're like,
well you got to pick it up and then you need to store it somewhere and then you
need to sell it out of somewhere.
I was like,
I'm starting to fucking do this whole thing.
Yeah.
And so I was like,
okay,
that's not what I wanted to do.
What did you want to do?
You want it to put your name on it and they deal with everything and wanted to
stamp my name on it and help promote it.
Then happened.
You could just,
you just need to get with a better company.
I can't whine.
Jeremy can do it.
You can do it.
Why can't it happen?
I've tried four times and every time it is the exact same thing is that you need
it like some managerial type people to take care of that shit for you.
I,
I've tried on your own.
I'm doing it on my own with my,
with my wife and it's just a fucking nightmare.
All due respect to you and your wife.
You're not,
you're not in the business.
No.
I should get someone who knows how to do it.
We did.
There was a guy that came out in Portland,
really nice and he came and met with me and he's like,
I've heard that you want to start a get through Joe's podcast,
let me do this.
And then we came in.
We had a big fucking tasting.
We selected our brand.
We liked it.
I got fucking everyone.
I mean,
everyone was in,
we did a tasting at my house.
Everyone tried it.
Everyone liked the exact same one.
Okay,
great.
Let's go.
And they're like,
you know,
quarter million dollars and what are you going to,
how are you going to distribute the progress?
Whoa,
whoa.
You had to give him a quarter billion dollars.
Not Him.
He,
he was doing it.
This guy was really cool.
We should remember his name.
He was really cool.
He just set me up and he was like,
I don't want,
I don't need a piece of it.
I want,
I like Joe's podcast.
I like you.
I think this would be a good thing for you.
I'll set you up with the people.
And as soon as it he did,
he moved out of it.
The people were like,
we want,
you've got to pay all this fucking money.
I was like,
I just want you to stamp it on.
Like that's not gonna happen.
So it's like,
it just is.
So it was a scam.
That's a scam.
It is kind of a scam.
They're there.
They want you to take all the risks.
They don't really want to be in business with you.
Right.
But what they'll do is they'll be your distributor,
they'll make your,
make your notes or your manufacturer manufacturer,
they'll make your whiskey and then you got to figure out how to get it into
stores.
Right.
And so it just was like a fucking,
I was like,
I'm done.
That seems like it's been such a pain in the ass that I,
and I and I,
you get so excited cause it gets so close and then it just falls apart.
You're like,
oh fuck it.
Yeah.
There's a kitten deed.
There's a website said actually,
you know,
dudes be like,
where you can start your own brand of like Fyedka or whiskey and stuff.
Like there's so much more to this that I'm not even sharing with you.
Apparently your label needs to be approved by the FDA.
So like,
so you can't,
it can't be as simple as just being on a website.
I only say that because we got to the places where it got really difficult.
And I was just like,
it's not worth our time.
Yeah.
That seems like a drag.
I'm telling you what man,
I'm going to do a fucking,
after I'm done with this book and I'm,
and I'm going back on the road,
I'm going bill burst style and I'm scrapping fucking material cause I feel like
I've,
I feel like I've been treading water artistically and not moving forward.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
You don't throw your shit out.
I they do a special my po,
I haven't done a special so long.
My problem is I write a lot on stage,
so I always have like 20 minutes and new stuff every night where I'm kind of
fucking around and figuring things out.
Um,
but like I got,
I got,
I got caught,
I got caught telling the machine story.
You know that machine story.
Everyone was different and I get it.
I totally want them to hear that they paid for the tickets.
Do you?
Right,
right.
Do you sit down in front of the computer?
And like I did with the book and with the book,
I found that my writing got exponentially better and tighter and I was like,
Holy Shit Man,
I'm,
I'm dealing with things because I wouldn't got into like the machine's story.
I told it in the book,
it is to row.
Like I talk about the dude I remember telling you about this,
but like I shortened it for stage.
There was another dude with me that whole night.
I really kind of got into the,
the how they got the money into the country to pay off the mafia.
And I,
you're like,
God dammit,
why wasn't I talking about this on stage before?
So writing really does help with that process of writing on stage and it just
makes it better.
Yeah.
I'm sure writing is everything,
man,
you know,
planet of the apes.
I got to remember that story.
Um,
I find that being on the podcast helps me,
uh,
do like doing my podcast helps me write material just in the,
in the sense that you come up with a thought and you're like,
oh,
that's fucking funny.
Do you do this?
Do you like,
this is mine.
Over the last few months we've had these legal pads.
I leave around here for the guests from me.
Anytime.
Something that you can't,
you know,
you got to remember,
you've got to go back to it later.
I just write shit down on these things.
I just started taping my sets.
I just started recently.
I don't like it because if I tape that I don't feel creative.
I feel like I'm not going to talk.
I feel like I'll work on material.
I know you say just tape every set and then it becomes normal.
I know I'm going to,
the problem is I don't listen to them a lot unless there's something really
genius happens.
You have it.
Look,
I have a hundred fucking plus sets on my,
on my phone at all times at any given time.
At any given time.
These are all different comedy sets.
Where do you get your phone out?
Off to the side.
I just put it on a stool as hundreds of sets,
man.
I think every comic does that nowadays.
It's on your phone.
Yeah,
I have one or two.
Tell you what,
when I was young there were two times,
and by the way,
I understand that I'm setting myself up to be slammed on this.
There are two types of topics.
I can't help it.
I like it.
I fucking,
I have miss hanging out like this.
There were two types of comics.
There were the guys that had tape recorders on stage and then there were the
black comics
and I liked the black comics,
like Mike Epps,
Mike Apps,
trashy,
Tracy Morgan.
And I know that me and him ain't never be friends.
My caps,
Tracy Morgan,
Dave Chappelle,
Tony Woods,
where the guys,
I never partied with Dave Chappelle by party,
a party with apps and apart.
It would Tony and,
and,
and I hung out with Chappelle one night like,
but not nothing big.
Right.
I'd watch him on stage and it was like they were creating in the moment.
Greer Barnes.
Do you remember Greer balling.
Bruce.
Hilarious.
I'll fucking monster it.
A lot of road gigs with Greer.
He is one of the best comics I've ever seen on stage.
It's a funny dude man.
He's always,
always shocked.
Did that guy didn't become famous.
There's a few of those guys.
Reggie McFadden is another one I talk about all the time.
Do you remember that?
Go understand it.
Reggie McFadden when we were living in New York.
Yeah,
well I was in new Rochelle.
I like 92 or something like that.
I saw Reggie Mcfadden Eta a black comedy club and all black comedy club in Mount
Vernon called the champagne comedy club.
I could never work it cause you had to be squeaky clean.
Yeah,
like does he do had all these rules?
No,
motherfuckers can't see.
No motherfucker know motherfucker.
He don't say the bitch had a big ass said the girl had a wide behind.
Like he would give you these things,
the way you describe things.
I was like,
well I'll never work at this place.
But at least I can go with my friend.
My friend was working there and he was working with Reggie Mcfadden and Reggie,
just a straw destroyed.
I remember watching him going,
Whoa,
this kid is talented.
And I remember thinking,
you know,
I was in my early twenties I Jess,
I was like 23 or 24 or something like that.
And I was thinking,
man,
this is so cool.
It's like to be a part of like this scene and you know,
being around these comedians and they're all going to be shooed someday.
The,
some of them for whatever,
Tony Woods.
So for some of them I just,
I don't get it.
How does Tony Woods not gigantic?
I don't know man.
Tony Woods.
It's fucking hot,
Larry.
Oh,
it's coming up.
Tony.
What was came to the DC Improv one night.
I wish.
Why don't people take these moments and it's only words.
It comes to DCM problem at night,
sold out.
Beautiful,
beautiful.
And He,
I hear him in the back.
Why don't you tell that Tracy Morgan story?
I said,
who is that?
And in my head,
I thought it's either one or two people.
It's either Tony Woods or Tracy Morgan.
Right,
right,
right.
And I said,
is that Tony?
Yeah,
Bert.
Tell that story.
Tell your story of that night.
And I went,
all right,
everyone in the guy that was there with me that night,
Tony Woods,
he's in the room.
I said,
Tony,
why don't you do this?
Why don't we come up on stage?
You come up,
you tell your side of the story.
I'll tell him my side of the story and we'll see where the two middles meat.
He's like,
that's what I want.
So he went up and down it goes up.
We have two mikes and we told the story and it's amazing to hear his words that
Oh yeah,
I got all fucking stage.
Fucking I'm,
and I told and I,
cause I,
cause one of my favorite things is I don't remember,
I don't remember anything.
But I wanted to know if Tony remembered the end of that night,
the exact same way I did with that same bill.
Burke.
Quite sure.
So I said to him,
I said,
uh,
and he's on the ground.
And Tony,
I remember Tony said,
all I'm thinking is,
well,
we can do with the dead.
Tracy Morgan man is going to ruin on Korea.
Burton and I go,
and then he stood up and I looked at Tony and he die.
I mean identical.
He goes,
he snapped a shirt and he looked,
he said,
now that's how you get out of paying the check and walked away.
And I was like,
fucking,
it was like one of those things where you've got proven that you didn't lie.
And I was like,
I fucking knew it.
It was like a on Facebook that people that know,
obviously the book's been out,
the people that were involved in the Russian train story of all heard about it.
And so they're all replying like,
yeah,
I was there 100% true.
That's fine.
And even when you hear it,
you're like,
I fucking knew it.
Like,
and you know,
you're telling the truth,
but it's just as a comic,
like you said,
your imagination takes over and you try to get the laugh.
And you never know.
Yeah,
it's,
it's weird when you go back and you think about those dudes like Reggie
Mcfadden.
So like regimen fatten.
Uh,
and this story,
it may not be accurate,
but this is how I remember it.
Regiment found word I'll do in a very cash showcase and the line is be clean.
Oh No,
who says that?
But I think it was Barry son of a bitch and Reggie McFadden goes up on stage and
his first joke is,
um,
let me tell you why he never supposed to eat strip a pussy.
Like I bet,
look,
I've fucking,
who fucking knows?
I don't want Reggie Mag upset by remember Hims Kinda clean.
It seemed,
it seemed,
it seemed fucking end.
He talked about if you're the first person he stripper pussy,
you're not,
you're not the first person he stripper pussy that night.
You're the fifth person and you're gonna get like,
it was a joke.
But that was the whole fucking premise.
I remember Barry in the back like ringing us and it's like,
I thought I said to work clean.
How come he didn't work clean?
Oh yeah,
we're cleaning is always so stupid.
Greer Barnes a monster.
Do you remember,
was it Hans,
do you remember a guy who had a joke about the Jamaican subway shooting?
No.
Remember the Jamaican guy that went on the long island expressway with the
rifle?
Yes.
Do you remember?
You don't remember the guy who,
the joke?
No,
one of the most murderous jokes I've ever seen and I wish I could remember it.
And then France,
France was his name.
I feel like I was out of New York by,
yeah,
I think I was already in a la black dude.
I remember when you first came out to La and you,
and I want to say,
I want to say I remember it because it was like you're done some article about,
uh,
about,
who was and wasn't funny anymore or something.
But I remember it was like maybe videotape,
but it was on your lot like,
and you were standing and you were telling him like,
Oh yeah,
that guy's not fucking funny.
Oh,
once,
I dunno.
I'm talking about trying to remember the best I can happen.
Really?
Yeah.
There's no way I was doing video saying who's not funny anymore that someone
used to be funny and isn't
confusing me with somebody else really,
cause I always thought it was you and I was
the only bed.
The best part is that I remember the best part was that I remember I guess
watching it with some people and Bobby Kelly was like,
aw man,
there goes all my acting gigs.
I looked just like the guy I fucking job Kelly.
She looked just like me and I can't remember.
I can't remember.
Kelly's my friend.
Yeah,
I know,
but I know him from a long time ago.
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
then it may not have been,
you know,
it wasn't me.
It wasn't you then?
No.
Bobby Kelly and I had sex in the same room together.
We picked up these two chicks and brought it back [inaudible] two chicks and
brought him back to his place.
Really?
I tried to do that with Dane one time.
Didn't Dame wasn't into it.
Dang got so pissed at me.
He's scared of you.
He was like,
no,
he's pissed.
He was like,
he's like bigger.
What if the CRO haunts you?
What if you're funnier?
He goes,
turn it off.
Burden.
Turn it off.
I go,
what?
And he goes to comedy.
We're done.
It's over.
Let's make this happen.
By the way,
she probably shouldn't be telling this story.
Probably Shit.
Jesus Christ.
We didn't fuck anyone.
Don't lie from here on out.
Just let it go.
Okay.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you that.
Picked up two girls.
Don't tell the story.
I'll tell you said,
tell the truth.
No,
no,
no.
Don't tell him we didn't fuck anybody.
Remember Dane,
the valuable lesson and that was Dame was like,
uh,
you're not gonna see my car.
Nope.
He goes,
uh,
he goes,
you got to learn when to turn it off.
I'm leaving.
He's always have to turn it off because I was being a comic in the bed and like,
I was trying to joke around and Danes like,
you're cock blocking the moment.
I trying to be funny.
We're done.
We did the stage show.
It's over,
mother fucker.
This is going to be the most,
I'm just burning bridges left and right on this podcast today.
He was like that.
I would advise not talking anymore.
We didn't have sex with anyone.
We just hung out with some girls.
Then that's over.
Whatever,
whatever.
Well,
you know there's some dudes that like they,
they will feel like you're fucking up their vibe if you're just constantly
hitting on the Yuk Yuks and they're trying to get some Barry white music plan.
That's me.
Yeah.
I'm not finding,
fuck yeah,
I'm not,
I can't,
I can't turn it off ever.
Like when you're having sex.
Yep.
I'll tickle you when I'm fucking,
if I turn it off,
if I turn it off during sex,
it looks completely
don't want all the other images that I have of you in my head.
They're all jammed together.
Now.
I can't,
I can't glean girls and they're just shaking their head looking at you like,
can you just shut it down and just go into sexy mode?
Oh yeah.
You know,
it's like people either have sexy mode.
It's like a toggle switch.
She knew when you were either,
hey,
I didn't work for it.
I'm not proud of it.
It's like something,
I was just born with
it or you don't Bro,
I don't have it
and I don't even know why I got it.
I got it.
Go.
Did you see Bobby Kelly sexy mode when you guys had sex with her
fucking hammered,
you know,
21 or so.
Do you ever,
ever let another dude see your sexy mode?
There's no sexy mode,
man.
We were laughing.
You know,
we,
we took these chicks,
we met them,
they were really cool.
We had a good time and next thing you know,
we're back at Bobby's place and I don't even think we thought we were going to
wind up actually having sex.
But next thing you know,
everyone's naked.
Really?
Yeah.
Bobby and his girl were over there and he gave me his bed.
He's fucking cool guy.
And me and this chick,
we're on Bobby's bed.
Horrible children.
We were were all children.
You know,
I was probably 24 I think.
Maybe somewhere around then love Bobby and Bobby was a shit.
Bobby was probably the same age or somewhere around there.
I think he's a little younger than me.
Yeah,
he's,
I think he's,
I want to say he's my age.
How old are you?
41.
Yeah.
Maybe it didn't make too much sense.
That doesn't make too much sense cause then he would be some 46,
he'd be five years.
Actually you'd be 20 at the time before I was 25 or 24.
He was in 19.
I don't think so.
I don't think he was that young.
But either way we were working together and it was when he was with a,
he had a commie team with Dane Cook.
They were Al and among the monkeys.
Yeah.
And Him and al and Dane and Bobby would do,
they would do sketches and then they would do like each do like five minutes to
stand up.
And uh,
then,
uh,
Dayne would do like the last bit and then I would go on up to those guys and I
would just do stand up.
Can we did a couple of gigs together like that.
By the way,
guys,
I'm not talking shit about Bobby.
And Dane,
please don't start.
If I was a good dude,
he's one of my favorite people.
I call them when I have drama.
Bad guy either.
He's just struggled.
Like many Comedians,
you know,
he's made his errors for sure,
but he's,
he suffered for those errors.
And there's a lot of,
uh,
there's a lot of value to that suffering for comedians.
Both value to the creative aspect of his suffering.
And you know,
the,
the originality aspect to the suffering.
When your originality is questioned,
you know,
everybody has thought of something that somebody had already thought of.
It just happens.
You know,
there's a lot of shit that's kind of,
I want to say obvious,
but it's available if you do the math,
you know,
and there's the real problem is when guys find out that they,
that there's a bit that already exists and they don't drop their own,
you're too thirsty,
then you're too hungry.
You're too,
and you're also not confident enough and you're not your own abilities because
your own abilities you should have,
you should have enough confidence in the fact that you put in the hours you work
on your writing,
you work on your craft,
you work on your,
your,
your idea of being an artist,
a standup comedian,
and what's the threat to that art?
Well,
you would say one of the big threats to that art is if you,
you're not original,
that's a threat.
If you can't be creative,
So if something comes along and then threatens that originality,
creativity,
you shouldn't say,
Hey,
but I'm still getting laughed at that sort of fuck it.
I'm going to keep going.
No,
what you should do is abandon that and concentrate solely on creating something
to fill its place.
Say,
oh,
there's a bit that like,
here's an example of one where I fucked up on and I don't even know.
I fucked up until years and years later I did a bit about penguins and it was
about that at that march of the penguins bit that remember that movie from March
of the penguins,
Morgan Freeman is hosting it.
And uh,
I did a bit about,
it's so obvious about,
you know,
penguins are monogamous,
but it's not that impressive because they look exactly the same.
It's not like one is Rosie O'donnell,
one looks like Jenna Jameson.
No,
it's the fucking penguins.
So you can pretend you're banging your sister or your mom.
They all have the same.
Yeah.
And uh,
Ellen did generous had a bit years before that and I didn't even hear it until I
was driving in my car and I was listening to a XM satellite radio at the time.
And they had the comedy hour or whatever it was.
Raw Dog.
Yeah.
And Ellen Degeneres was talking about penguins looking exactly the same.
Like why it's not that impressive.
They're monogamous.
They look exactly the same.
It's so obvious.
It's right there.
But if I had heard her do it,
I would have never done it.
But I think she got there first.
I think like the,
the year of her,
her bit precedes the Year of mine cause I think she didn't have even mentioned
the march of the penguins.
I think it was before March of the penguins even came out.
That's one of the,
one of the biggest fears of your young comic is,
is if you're afraid to listen to people's albums because you're afraid they're
going to do bits like you.
Yeah.
You need to fucking start writing more.
Well,
you know,
Jim Norton doesn't listen to other comedians for that very reason.
He doesn't like going to comedy.
No.
You gotta you got do and already said this already.
And I did a podcast,
uh,
this week about my first album ever and Ori was extremely critical of it and
rightfully so.
That's the reason we did,
are we wrapping up?
We can close to minutes.
We got five minutes.
And so Ari was extremely critical of it.
But I've said that's why I want to do this.
I want to look at one of me when I was young and fucking really bad and hungry
and dirty and not clean about what I wanted or my dreams,
my hopes,
because I don't want people to hear me,
just me and him just glad hand me on on a fucking,
on a,
on a CD.
And we did.
And there was a,
that was a lot of my fears of young.
It was just,
Oh just don't want your feet.
I want to be a headliner.
You've gotta do,
you've gotta let the base be the pace.
Well you also have to fuck up and learn long.
You have to fuck up and learn.
I'm taking a big sabbatical after I wrapped this and I'm going to fucking right
and work and just start hanging out at clubs.
But you got to watch young comics and find out what they're doing sometimes.
Cause you got to know where the,
where the fucking,
where the meter is.
Like who,
if I got to like art who was handling the thing,
if there's crocodile,
have a hundred bits were a big deal.
Well,
if you weren't in the clubs,
you didn't realize everyone had a fucking crocodile hunter bits.
Everybody.
Yeah.
And so I avoided it and I'd fucking have an obsession with lizards cause you
don't want to be the guy with a crocodile bit hunter bit also,
dude,
I have a lizard skin ramp on my pool cue.
I have cases
that are made out of alligator skin.
How obsessed with reptiles and the whole thing about this crocodile hunter,
this guy drove me crazy,
but I would never talk about him because of the fact there was so many.
But you would go on stage at the comedy store and if you had a 10 o'clock spot,
the show starts at eight there might be three guys before you,
they did a fucking crocodile hunter choke.
I don't want that.
I don't want to be the guy.
Go,
hey,
did anyone do the thing about blow jobs?
I have a ton of blow jobs.
Too late,
too late,
too late.
Here's what I like.
Blow jobs.
That's my Dave.
A towel.
Love that guy.
Yeah,
there's so many fake David tells out there.
Put me in that group.
No,
you don't do a David when you're younger,
you don't know what you're doing on stage and you emulate you don't,
you ready for what I'm doing?
Okay.
I talked to Fitzsimmons the other day.
He was on my podcast.
I'll,
I'll probably release it tomorrow.
Fitzsimmons is going to,
uh,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna pay him and he's gonna sit and vet my hour.
Oh,
that's a good move.
Fitzsimmons is a brutal critic and he's smart as fuck and he's a real good
comic.
He's like,
he's like,
you know what bird,
I'll tell you what you don't need.
And I'll tell you what's hacky.
I'll tell you where you should go.
And then you may not be ready for another hour.
You may need to work.
But he's like,
you know,
you gotta do this.
You've got to do that.
Well,
a lot of guys who've done that,
like Chris rock did that when he created new hours,
you had nick Depaulo Rich Vos and they would write for him.
Right.
Idea.
I don't want Greg to write for me,
I'm very strict about that.
I write my own material.
I say my own material,
if it comes out of my mouth,
it's mine forever.
But I would like Greg too.
I don't mind Greg punching up a joke or helping me with the joke.
Right.
But I,
I,
but I,
I want him to tell me what is not what I'm better then.
No one's better to tell anything.
Greg.
Yeah,
he's a fucking,
Greg's one of the,
one of the fucking guys that,
because I'm a friend with you,
I've become friends with him.
He's a smart dude.
And also what I'm grateful for my friendship with you.
Let's wrap this up.
I'm grateful for my friendship with Youtube.
This has been a cool family to be involved in and it,
it is a,
it's one of the things I say,
I said to Stan hope is one of my favorite things is the fact that I've earned
the right to call myself a stand up comedian and then have real conversations
with real people like you guys because it's,
you can't get this at a country club.
No.
Well,
I think,
you know,
as we,
we,
Moshe Kasher yesterday we were talking about like all comics are like the only
people that truly understand comics.
Yeah.
No one's going to get us.
It's just,
it's so weird to be that kind of a fuck up and outside or that comes up with
these ideas that other people are just,
I mean,
some people are going to be funny upon occasion.
There's going to be a stress build up and someone's going to be the guy that
busts the bubble and release it and everyone's going to go,
Whoa,
John.
So funny.
Yeah.
There's a real difference between that and an Ari Shaffir.
There's a real difference between that and a craftsmen who's out there.
Joey Diaz or Doug,
Stan Hope,
Stan hope.
I love them.
We own,
you know,
it's hard for other people to understand each other.
That's why I've always been so supportive of other comedians and I think it's
real important.
It was really important to me when I,
when I first started out to get the green light and the approval from other
comedians like I've talked about
on the podcast.
I'm Mark Marin gave me like a little pep talk once when I was an open miker
changed my world.
Like I was convinced I could do it if this guy,
Mark Mann was a,
he was a real pro.
He was coming back from the comedy store,
but he knew that he was,
he used to work at the comedy store in La,
which was Mecca.
That was like this guy had been to Jerusalem or some shit,
you know,
I mean,
and when he told me I was good,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm good.
Oh I'm going to really do this.
Like that,
those little moments for a comic to,
despite I bombed a fucking thousand times after that.
I mean everybody bombs,
everybody eats deck.
But that's also part of trying to find your voice and trying to find your,
your,
your material and trying to figure out.
It ain't easy.
It ain't easy to do this.
And we all need each other.
Dude,
look at,
look at my life from when I met you guys.
But like,
I mean,
like I say this,
I blow smoke up your ass a lot.
I've told me to stop,
but like Brian's wearing my shirt,
my book's out today and I'm hanging out.
We're all still friends and,
and I'm telling them machine story on stage,
I would have never fucking told had I not met you.
I would have never told him I love you buddy.
But you would have,
I wouldn't even navigate it out one day you would have got to a point where
like,
I need some new material.
I was in Russia and then it would just,
I would just start taking it up.
Look,
we help each other,
man.
But you know,
you are just as important to me as I am to you.
You know?
And Brian,
you're just as important to me as I am to you.
To all of you,
Jamie.
I could do with or without you.
Bye.
[inaudible] I don't mean that.
No,
we,
we all feed off of each other and it's what you make out of these relationships
that is like,
that's sort of your responsibility when you're around as many talented people as
you can.
If you just sort of lay back and become the guy where everybody goes to the
fucking,
you know,
Timmy doesn't write new jokes.
This mother fucker is bombing all the time.
We bring him on the road,
it has the same jokes he did a year ago and he's eating Dick.
Then Tim is not doing his part and then Timmy winds up getting cut out of the
fucking Rose Bush and that's just how it goes.
And it's all for all of us to,
it's important.
Look,
I have benefited from being friends with all of the people in this room,
but I've also benefited from being friends with Dunkin,
from being inspired by him,
by being inspired by Joe Arr or your Doug or just,
you know,
fill the fill in the blank.
Keep going.
Hello.
Almost got my computer again.
My fucking Italian hand gestures.
Jesus Christ.
Look at it.
It's trying to find my computer like a fucking,
like a one of those lampreys in a um,
Shannon Doherty movie.
Yes.
I watched the attack of the killer lampreys
Shannon Doherty,
she's back.
I is back on the way here.
I was like,
wait,
you don't listen to the Smith?
Let's go get weird tone.
Netta.
He's an interesting man.
Femmes take us out
on the song called drugs,
drugs,
find tone,
ETA drugs,
drugs,
drugs online.
And you'll kind of understand what I'm saying and now,
and I'll read off,
uh,
what we need to cover on this podcast.
Crusher.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the life of the mother fucking party.
Fucking love you,
Jo.
I put up a link earlier today on Amazon.
Go to my Twitter and you can buy his book.
It is a symbol of the tours.
This guy's doing this shit in his living room and his underwear.
They'll take them away from me.
I'm happy doing drugs.
Sounds like shit.
It actually sounds pretty good to me.
Yeah.
He's fascinating.
Violet.
Tim's a great fucking good.
Is who he is.
That guys,
him,
that's him.
And he's bombing.
He's doing are.
And rather,
I like them.
I like all good.
All right,
you fucks.
Listen,
we will be back on Saturday night for some sort of a UFC fight.
What are we calling them?
Fight companion podcast,
most likely be Callin Brendan Walsh,
Eddie Bravo and me.
And we're going to watch the fights and we're going to talk some shit.
And allegedly marijuana might be distributed.
If someone wants someone to bring a bottle of wine and get my show in Philly,
how dare you.
It's available for download later.
You don't have to skip any shows live in the moment.
Remember the moon that no recordings live of the fucking moment.
Alright,
you dirty flux.
We'll be back soon.
Uh,
rogan.ting.com go there and save 25 bucks on the new android device.
The sexiest of the sexy,
including the HTC one m eight,
which I have my dirty little eyeballs on.
Thank.
Thank thanks.
Uh,
thanks to uh,
[inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off of
any and all supplements for a limited edition and Kitty cat tee shirts and all
of the information about podcasts and uh,
any of,
uh,
Brian's comedy dates.
Go to desk squad.tv and get your freak on.
Including this Friday night.
We'll be at the ice house in Pasadena in the little room doing an episode of
Thunderpussy,
which is a completely improvisational podcast.
The audience yells,
had ideas.
He'd go onstage,
blitzed out of your fucking mind,
and you talk mad shit,
and it's probably the funnest thing I've ever done in my life.
How you around Friday night?
I'm in Philly.
Go Fuck Yourself,
Philly from me.
How dare you,
Bill.
Bill was right.
All right,
well,
we'll see you fucks on Saturday night.
Must love big kiss to everybody.